Para fazer hoje. Deixa eu compartilhar minha tela.
E a gente começa.
Beleza. Eu vou multar todo mundo, tá? Eu vou parar em alguns momentos. Vocês podem levantar a mão.
Eu tiro dúvidas com vocês.
E para vocês. E com vocês.
Mas por enquanto, deixa eu multar vocês aqui. Só um minutinho.
Beleza pessoal tão bem.
Boa noite. Todo mundo, bem vindos ao nosso primeiro dia do booticamp de engenharia genética.
A ideia é que a gente.
Vê de fato.
Todos os anéis de engenharia que nós temos hoje em dia a dia.
A gente vai trabalhar aí.
Uma semana inteira.
Vestindo lentes diferentes, entendendo.
Um problema. Então esse é um novo estilo nosso, de como a gente vai.
Passar conhecimento, tanto de fundamento quanto na prática, quanto da experiência.
Dentro sempre de um caso de uso real.
E eu resolvi trazer um caso de uso não só real.
Mas complexo, tá? E muita gente aqui tem vários níveis, tá? A gente tem gente.
Começando agora. A gente tem gente intermediária. A gente tem gente avançada.
A primeira coisa é, não tem como entender tudo em cinco dias, é impossível entender tudo em cinco dias. Se Você Entender Tudo Parabéns Mas A Ideia é Que Você Não Entenda.
Entretanto, você vai ter o repositório para consultar constantemente.
A gente vai passar aqui passo a passo. Então a gente vai ter isso gravado e a gente vai ter Um Cycle De Brain Onde Você Possa Perguntar.
A grande questão no final do dia é.
A gente vai sempre olhar, a partir de agora, como um engenheiro agêntico, como literalmente um profissional. Ai, Native.
aqu
And the bus station delay.
From Yoshi
Belize. Tao, oje, agente va eve pouquinho la parte borge, entendemento do problema. Y ahir limbra ne equipalo prequel compaulas, aqui
No problem statement.
Entender isso para a gente, já ver com essas lentes hoje amanhã a gente vai trabalhar muito mais a lente de um software engineer entendeu um pouquinho, como que ele vai quebrar um problema, como ele vai desenhar o design pattern como que ele vai orquestrar essa solução.
Como software e não como data Engineer. Então a gente vai falar.
sobriso.
E puffin, a de cho a coordena uma fabrica.
Cada dia a gente vai se comportar com uma Skill ou com uma role.
Now you pensar ali em cada um desses tipos.
E no final, a gente vai construir uma fábrica autônoma. Tá.
E aí, quando você pensa nessa fábrica, o que você tem que entender? Ela é canônica.
Então você pode utilizar tanto para criar código de Databrics como você pode usar para fazer tradução de Java para Python Como Você Pode Utilizar Para Fazer Imigração De Post Para Express.
Tanto faz. Você tem o requisito. Você quebra isso em processos técnicos. Quebra em.
Atividades, executa as atividades e coloca tudo isso num loop para executar. Então a ideia é trazer para vocês como Vocês Vão Construir Esse Sistema Para Que Vocês Possam Utilizar.
Fim a fim, tá? E aí? Obviamente que eu vou trazer algumas coisas para reduzir drasticamente o tempo em que Você Iria Parar Para Construir Essa Fábrica Então No Final.
Você vai ter um framework que você vai seguir, que ele vai te dar tudo. Basicamente.
Lembrando que a grande importância da gente aqui.
Entender o problema. Se a gente não conseguir entender o problema, a gente não vai conseguir resolver o que realmente é para resolver.
Outra coisa.
A gente tem a entrada e o início do dia.
Tá? A gente não tem.
Se vai dar certo ou não. Eventualmente vai dar certo, obviamente. Mas o que eu quero dizer é que é algo construído.
Então, se a gente parar por uma hora, der algum problema, der algum Bug, a gente tem que voltar.
Alguém me ajudar. Enfim, é o processo, tá? Esse é o processo. Mesmo a gente vai construir Live juntos. Então Não Vai Ser Nada.
Em que eu pratiquei trezentas vezes. A gente tem um requisito processo e a gente vai construir isso juntos, tá.
Então pode ter vários pios aí. Pode funcionar na minha máquina. Pode ter problema com vocês assim por diante. A Gente Vai Resolvendo Como Um Time.
Beleza. Qual o problema que a gente vai atacar?
A gente vai atacar um problema muito interessante, muito complexo, que é um processo, um problema financeiro.
E eu quis pegar um problema financeiro. Vou falar. Por quê? Eu poderia pegar vários outros problemas primeiro.
Eu estou trabalhando nesse projeto há mais de nove meses fora do país. Então eu estou viajando, inclusive na sexta Feira Gente Eu Vou Mandar A Comunicação.
A gente vai ter que começar mais cedo, porque eu viajo duas horas da manhã pra aqui.
Do sábado. Então vou ter que terminar o Booticamp e ir direto para o aeroporto. Então, acho que a gente Começa às Sete Horas Mais Ou Menos Eu Termino Umas Dez No Máximo Para Poder Ir Embora.
Mas enfim, eu vou entregar lá esse final desse projeto. Então esse projeto aqui que vocês estão vendo é um projeto real.
Só que em anonimizado, obviamente, né.
Então, em vez de ser curve, Pay, vai ser North Windpay.
Mas o processo é exatamente o mesmo. Só não vou usar os dados do cliente, então é um caso de Uso Extremamente Complexo Que Envolve Finanças.
Que envolve cobol, verpunt.
Que envolve uma cacetada de coisas que vocês vão aprender tanto na lente de engenheiro quanto na lente de arquiteto Quanto Na Lente De Ai Engineer Quanto Na Lente De Engenheiro De Software.
Beleza. Bem, o que é? O que a gente chama de Psp Payment Service Provider é um cara que está Basicamente Entre A Compra.
E entre literalmente ou cá onde essa compra passada. Então pô se você tem lá, você está passando isso. Você Faz Um Swipe Lá No.
Na maquininha, né?
Basicamente, o que acontece. Esse dado sai de lá e teoricamente, bate na Visa, no Mastercard e assim por diante.
Só que isso realmente não acontece em relação à transação. A aceitação da transação acontece em tempo real. Entretanto.
Esse pagamento e toda essa parte de processamento.
Existem muitas empresas nos Estados Unidos que fazem esse medware.
Principalmente se você tiver charge back. Se você tiver uma transação que pode ser fraude ou assim por diante. Você Tem Aqui No Meio Alguém Que Vai Interceptar Isso.
Então a gente, na verdade, vai ser exatamente essa entidade que vive entre.
Os mexãs que a gente chama.
Mission pode ser tanto um cliente quanto pode ser uma empresa.
Quanto, literalmente, essa aceitação do swaping do cartão.
Para que possa ser literalmente aprovado no banco, tá? Então a gente está aqui no meio. Esse Acquire.
Esse cara aqui, beleza. Então a gente vai entender o processo. O nosso processo como empresa.
é literalmente processar arquivos que acontecem, que caem no Sftp de tempos em tempos. Tá.
Geralmente uma quiet. Ela não processa em tempo real.
Geralmente ela tem tempos para processar, até pela quantidade de chunks de transação. Se aquela transação foi aceita ou foi Cancelada Para Você Ter Um Novo Registro Se Ela Vai Ter Charge Back.
Por isso que, às vezes, quando você vai fazer reembolso, por exemplo, você tem sete dias no cartão de crédito, por exemplo.
Porque você está sendo ali encaminhado para um cara no Middleware para fazer isso. Então esse é o nosso.
Caso de uso, tá? Se tiver alguma dúvida aqui, vai colocando no chat que eu vou respondendo. Vocês.
E daqui a pouco eu faço pausas. Aqui tá.
O nome do Brasil adquirente é literalmente a mesma coisa que no Brasil. Os adquirentes são basicamente as maquininhas. Pronto, Perfeito Então A Gente Já Fez Essa Analogia.
There tem as maquininhas aí que fazem essa parte do midware.
E ganho uma transação. Uma taxa ali no meio, né?
Beleza.
Só que as coisas quando a gente olha o que eu chamo de três feat view quando a gente olha de longe, né?
Parece bem. Básicas, né?
Obviamente. Então, basicamente, o que a gente quer entender é.
Eu passo cartão. Isso é aprovado. Estou feliz e assim por diante. Mas existe um processamento que acontece por debaixo dos panos.
E daí que a gente vai ver.
Como funciona o nosso caso de uso aqui.
Então imagina que, de tempos em tempos de madrugada, o que acontece é.
A gente tem um novo arquivo que chega em formato. Dat.
Ele chega dentro do Sftp dentro de uma pasta chamada Raw Raw Incoming. Tá.
Então, toda noite eu tenho um bet gigantesco das transações que aconteceram. Elas caem ali dentro.
E, obviamente, como o sistema atual que acontece é.
A planta do sistema. A gente tem um Java.
Que basicamente lê esses arquivos que estão no Enccoming.
E daí? Basicamente, o que ele vai fazer é fazer o. Passem desses arquivos. Vai entender. Cada formato desse arquivo Vai Checar O Contrato.
O contrato. Basicamente, é a nossa fonte da garantia de que aque.
Arquivo bate com aquela tradução feita pela Indign. Então a gente tem um contrato.
A gente vai ver isso logo. Mais.
Essa informação, ela passa por uma série de transformações, por exemplo, messing anonimação e assim por diante.
E daí? Ela é copiada para dentro de um postcurso numa área de staging, onde a gente tem vários.
Historic procedures. E daí? Essas informações são literalmente enviadas para os mexicanos, onde eles podem fazer pesquisas e assim por Diante O Time Vai Olhar Vai Entender Transações E Assim Por Diante.
Se esses caras tiverem um problema.
No trailer e a gente vai entender. O que é isso?
Então, basicamente, o Java recusa. Envia esses caras.
Para um local aonde eles vão ser olhados posteriormente dentro.
Do Sftp. Até aqui tudo bem.
Quero ter certeza que todo mundo está entendendo cada pedaço, porque a gente.
Vai entrar em alguns detalhes chatos aqui.
Tem uma galera que já trabalha aqui, que eu conheço com main frame. Enfim, que vai ser fácil.
é tipo eu ler, mas não é básico para todo mundo que passa por isso, tá.
Quero ter certeza que todo mundo entendeu.
Então, no frigir dos ovos, a gente recebe informações no Sftp.
Tem uma aplicação no meio que pega esses arquivos. Cruz.
Transformam, mandam eles para o Postcress e dos postcers. Eles passam por uma série de store procedures que vão traduzir Esse Arquivo E Deixar.
O dado final disponível para a gente.
Mas tem um problema.
E o problema é um problema muito sério, inclusive, tá.
E é um problema em que.
A gente consegue aqui facilmente identificar se uma Llm ou se quem criou o processo ou se o processo criado. Ele Realmente é Bom O Bastante Ou Não.
E daí que eu quis trazer um problema financeiro.
Porque fica indiscutível como Llm pode ser extremamente eficaz ou não. Se você souber lidar com o problema.
Fora isso, você não consegue.
For, tentar utilizar Llm para projetos de garagem é uma coisa.
Mas quando a gente está tentando escrever algo em nível Enterprise.
As coisas são no dígito, ainda mais financeiro. São no um. Tres. Um, dois. Tem que ser extremamente perfeito.
Então, se a gente abrir um arquivo. Olha só. Que interessante. Então a gente vai ver. Na verdade, ao longo dos dias.
Nós iremos trabalhar com cinco tipos de arquivos diferentes.
E no último dia, a gente vai ver a fábrica se adaptando a um novo arquivo que vai ser recebido.
Mas olha só. Que interessante nesse arquivo, que é o arquivo que a gente chama de Valid Minimal. Dutch.
é o menor arquivo viável. Nós temos aqui três grandes características nesse arquivo.
A primeira. A gente tem um Header. Ele não é um Jason. Ele não é um Csv. Ele é um Arquivo De Fixed Width.
Ele tem tamanho fixo, beleza.
E ele é um tipo de card settlement. Tá.
Então é literalmente para a gente avaliar as transações do cartão.
E o que a gente tem aqui, né? A gente tem o Header.
E aqui, entre esse espaço, a gente identifica qual número do Bet.
Qual o Header dele com o número dele.
A gente tem duas informações importantes aqui no detalhe desse documento, que é o Bet da transação.
Então, olha só. Que interessante nesse.
Nesse pedaço que a gente valida. Qual é o valor.
Dessa transação, né? Então, se a gente olhar essas duas linhas aqui, nós temos dois valores, cento e vinte e Três Quarenta E Cinco E Cinquenta.
Entretanto, tem uma pegadinha muito gostosa aqui, que eu sofri bastante.
Que se chama Kobolver Punch.
Então, no cobol, a gente tem algumas formas de expressar.
O valor. Então, por exemplo.
Quando a gente olha esse cara é ele equivale a cinco.
Quando a gente olha esse cara aqui, ele equivale a zero.
Então, o que acontece no final do dia? O número. Ele vem.
Com alguns Cobols Overpants.
No meio. Isso é complexo.
Porque os números precisam bater. E a gente precisa avaliar o cobol e ter uma forma de traduzir essas informações.
Então, basicamente, eu estou pegando essa parte do detalhe.
E eu estou traduzindo ela para sessenta e vinte e três, quarenta e cinco, que é o último do e vale cinco.
E aqui, no final, a gente tem quinhentos.
Esse caracter que vale zero, cinquenta.
Então, se a gente somar cento e vinte e três, quarenta e cinco com cinquenta, a gente vai ter cento E Dezassete E Três E Catorze E Cinto.
Que é exatamente o que o trailer nos diz.
So cara. Só que legal. Pode acontecer casos.
é que o trailer.
Não diz o mesmo número.
Mas isso vai ser validado pela Ia. Vocês já conseguem ver o problema?
Se você não tem um Ivol aqui.
Vai passar. O que. Que passa? Uma validação, por exemplo. Olha, eu tenho a quantidade de, sei lá, quarenta caracteres aqui.
Ou cem, vinte. Tem beleza? Eu tenho aqui também.
Legal nos espaços do carácter entre vinte e três a quarenta e cinco, por exemplo.
Eu tenho um valor. Tem.
Mas como você sabe que esse valor está correto?
Então, nesse caso, aqui a gente tem que entender que o trailer vai ser a soma desses dois, né?
E ele vai vir no final. O valor da transação cento e setenta e três, quarenta e cinco.
Então aqui a gente vai ter as informações do Header. A gente vai ter as regras do que vem.
E a gente vai ter o valor total no final.
Beleza.
Entretanto.
Pode acontecer coisas assim maravilhosas. Por exemplo.
Pode acontecer que eu recebo um arquivo.
Mas o Bet pode ter vindo, por exemplo, em vez de. E ele vem com D.
E daí? O D. Na verdade, significa quatro em vez de cinco.
Identification. A gente tem. A gente tem que identificar que esse Bet. Que esse arquivo.
Ele não está correto com o trailer.
Então a gente tem que verificar no nível.
Overpunch.
Para verificar se esses valores batem.
E a razão da gente conseguir fazer isso.
é conseguir identificar o zero um.
Será que o nosso processo de fábrica será que o nosso processo com Llm.
Vai ser capaz de identificar esse tipo de problema.
Porque se a gente conseguir identificar e corrigir esse tipo de problema, a gente consegue garantir.
Na precisão.
Que o nosso processo agêntico funciona com cem de exatidão.
Uma coisa importante de vocês entenderem é que ser agênico não quer dizer que é não deterístico.
A Llm é não determinística. Entretanto, as ferramentas que ela chama do Hardness pode ser determinística.
Então, quando uma Llm fala Opa, eu posso chamar ali um sh, ou eu posso chamar um arquivo.
Uma Clay para fazer a validação de um kobolverpoint para mim.
Daí a gente tem uma Llm que é não determinística, chamando algo.
Que vai te trazer algo determinístico.
E daí? O reasoning em relação a isso também vai ser não determinístico, mas existem formas da gente guiar a Llm.
Para que ela se comporte. Que ela tenha resultados determinísticos.
Beleza. E a gente vai ver muito. Por exemplo, o que são regras.
O que é um Tdd? O Td não vai conseguir captar esse. Capturar esse tipo de problema que a gente tem.
Não com Lm. Ele vai fazer teste. Ele vai conseguir validar, mas não necessariamente. A Ia vai conseguir te dizer Se Esse Número Aconteceu Ou Não.
O que a gente vai ter que fazer ao longo desses dias, né?
Criar mecanismos, como por exemplo, Ivols, que a gente vai ver lá no quarto e no quinto dia.
De como resolver esse tipo de problema, não resolver, de garantir.
Que a gente tenha, né?
A soma do dado correto.
Em vez de estar faltando zero, um, por exemplo.
E aí? é um caso interessante. Só para abrir aspas para vocês.
Esse problema aqui. Ele veio de um problema real no cliente. Olha só. Que interessante.
Eu estava fazendo a tradução dos arquivos dele. Só que eles não utilizam Java. Eles utilizam outra.
Auto mechanism atual hoje. Eles utilizam Store procedures. Eles colocam isso dentro do Sql. Enfim.
Então eu estava fazendo toda a tradução para Python. Enfim.
E daí? Eu tinha criado uma fábrica. Essa fábrica funciona hoje, vinte e quatro x sete.
Que basicamente aprende com os erros. E uma das coisas que a Llm identificou.
é que existia não só o cobalver Punch, mas que existia um problema. Na verdade, no sistema fonte.
Então, na verdade, ele identificou exatamente isso aqui. Zero um que estava sendo mandado do arquivo de detalhe.
Para o arquivo de trailer. Ele estava errado.
E esse processamento estava executando aproximadamente tres a quatro anos.
E Daí Eu Passei Isso Pro Time Deles E Eles Tiveram Aproximadamente Cento E Setenta E Nove Mil Dólares De retorno com a Application de Thirty Party Applications, porque a gente identificou o problema na fonte do sistema.
Ou seja, não só a gente fez isso para ele, como a gente identificou uma fonte no oráculo deles, onde Realmente O Arquivo Seguia.
Porque existia um problema.
Então, por exemplo, esse é o lugar onde a gente consegue realmente garantir.
Que esse processo vai ser realmente cem.
Isso é uma coisa legal, como a gente vai criar isso? Então a gente vai passar por esse processo como um todo.
Porque aqui que vem o legal.
Muita gente vai validar o arquivo.
E se a gente fizer o Parsing desse arquivo?
Cara. Ele vai fazer o Parsing, correto.
Os tipos dele são válidos. Os campos estão presentes.
Mas, por exemplo, nesse df source, um.
O valor não bate. Então, muitas das vezes você vai ter uma validação que vai olhar a estrutura.
Que vai fazer o passo binding que vai verificar se os campos estão.
Vai verificar se aqueles registros são legais, mas você não vai validar o valor.
Isso evolve. Vai fazer pra gente, tá? Então é isso que a gente quer identificar. Porque passar no teste dá Green.
Não quer. Não significa que isso está certo.
Então a gente vai destilar esse problema ao longo da semana.
Verdinho não quer dizer que está certo.
Já falar um pouquinho sobre isso.
Bem como que a gente vai atacar isso, né?
Então a gente vai obviamente utilizar.
Hey, Lady. Para trabalhar com a gente.
E aí? Hoje é no mercado. Sinceramente falando, existem diversas llms. Cada um aqui pode trabalhar do jeito que quiser, Inclusive Esse é Um Experimento Muito Foda Que Eu Acho Que Vocês Não Têm.
Acho que vocês não têm noção. Mas olha só. Pensa comigo.
São cem, quinze e três pessoas aqui. Imagina comigo.
Cada um vai usar uma Llm diferente, com uma Ide diferente.
Com um processo diferente.
Imagine se no final de todas as aulas, a gente chegar no mesmo resultado. Isso quer dizer o quê?
A experiência que a gente vai passar aqui.
Você nunca viveu na sua vida.
Que você vai ter em uma semana a certeza de que, por exemplo, o sol se comportou bem.
O Cloud não fez muito bem. O Grok fez muito bem o Química três demorou um pouquinho, mas fez com exatidão.
Aqui é um ambiente de teste para a gente. Para todos nós, como engenheiros, validarmos com as Llms que comportam Ao Longo De Cada Ambiente Isso é Um.
Puta! Experimento.
Muito, muito foda. Tá.
Então, antes da gente começar, eu quero saber qual o setup que vocês vão utilizar aqui. Todo mundo tá digitem.
é para vocês estarem comigo aqui. Live.
Vocês vão usar o que? Ah, eu vou usar. Sei lá. O Cloud.
Na ide. Ah, não. Eu vou usar o cloud.
No verse code. Eu vou usar o Kimi no All My Pie. O que vocês vão usar? Eu quero saber O Que Vocês Vão Usar Os Dois.
Então, gente aqui, Cloud, codecode, conversa e code.
Codecs com orca.
Verse. Code Cloud não vence. Code Orca.
Super engineering.
Claudio Vest Code.
Claudio Super Engineering.
Cláudio, Vascode.
Ago, Cloud. Muita gente com Claud legal Codecs, Concursor.
Legal. Boa Ju. é Adriano. Claudio Gilberto Cloud Ves Code. Vou usar os dois Cloud Codecs. Acho muito legal se Vocês Puderem Utilizar Dois Ou Três Utilizem é Muito Bom Esse Teste.
Ainda mais que você. Está em um ambiente complexo e controlado.
Quem está na formação, obviamente, tem acesso à gravação. Esse budicamp foi colocado como.
é um bônus dentro da formação em todo mundo. Tem a gravação.
Cursor. Eu sou muito bom. Cloud code.
Code X Cli Legal.
Mas balunilha. Um gosto.
Jaminai pô. Tá aí curioso pra saber como que o Geminai vai. Vai se comportar. Tá, Max? Muito bom.
é um bom teste, cara. Usa anti Gravity e Gemini. Vamos ver como ele vai se comportar.
Com um processo tão ansioso para ver cara pra mim, um dos melhores momentos e mais aguardados pra mim. Esse treinamento.
Particularmente falando que eu acho que todo mundo vai aprender.
Muito. E esse teste para mim, ele é o mais excitante de todos.
A gente vai sair com uma semana sabendo cara o que funcionou bem, o que não funcionou no caso de uso complexo.
Então você vai ver literalmente a capacidade da Llm que você está utilizando.
Vers Code Linux, orca Cloud Code.
Vesse um Mypye Gpt cinco. Só mais Opus quatro oito. Revisando. O Bruno já está num ambiente um pouco mais complexo.
Que ele tem um revisor dentro do online, Pie. Gosto bastante. Também.
Cloud orca Open super engineering Anti Gravity.
Codex mais Ed legal. Já usei Zed também.
Vou usar dois ambientes College para garantir o resultado. E Open Code mais trinta e cinco Bi a local.
Vamos ver. Acho que ele não vai conseguir. Não tá? O tres a.
Mas está aí um bom ambiente para a gente testar.
Time muito bom também, cara. Ninguém falou que eu vou usar. Recomendo usar o Agent Harness Best Code.
Qual a opção do Super Engineering para o pode tentar, Orca. Ele é bom, Jeepcyk. Eu vou usar jepsick e Eu Vou Usar Grox.
Eu vou utilizar. Ninguém falou. Grock aqui.
Para mim hoje, o melhor modelo que eu tenho trabalhado é o grock. Então eu vou utilizar muito grok: Além De Ser Extremamente Rápido Tá.
Então eu vou usar o Groc para vocês verem beleza. Então, uma coisa. A gente tem os sistemas agênticos. Então, cloud codecs kim groc Open Code e as ideias que Você pode utilizar ou o próprio harness em si.
E você tem os conteúdos ali. Como por exemplo? Você pode ter o wipi, que é um.
Multi harness que fica em cima desse cara. é um cara que particularmente, eu acho.
Incrível. O Bruno que me mostrou, inclusive o Bruno. Está aí? Muito bom. Dá pra fazer muita coisa legal com ele.
Eu vou utilizar o super engineering, tá? é porque eu tô no Max.
E a gente também pode protestar vários modelos. Se você quiser utilizar o Open router.
E a gente tem o cimax também, que é um multiper, né?
Tem um Hurdle. Tem o C. Max tem.
Vários também nessa área de ser Life. Eu vou usar bastante o super engine. Fica fácil pra gente navegar entre eles. Beleza.
Então, para não demorar muito, a primeira coisa que a gente vai fazer é cetar o nosso ambiente, obviamente, né.
Então a gente vai navegar um pouquinho aqui, já no Repositório.
Desde a primeira até o quarto para todo mundo estar na mesma mesma página. Beleza. Preciso que todo mundo seja na mesma página.
Para a gente ir avançando. Então todo mundo cem aqui comigo, tá.
Aedes liga o celular. Vive essas vinte horas aqui.
Aqui está toda a minha experiência de um ano trabalhando com isso aqui, então assim vocês vão conseguir pegar Muito nugget legal para você incorporar no seu workload para você aprender coisas, não tem? Como tá.
Então vocês vão passar uma semana intensa comigo. Então, cara, usa essa semana intensa o melhor possível.
Pô. Eu trabalhei o dia inteiro. Enfim, todos nós aqui trabalhamos o dia inteiro. Todo mundo está cansado, mas, cara, Bebe Um Café Dá Seu Jeito E Vamos Até.
Meia noite, tá, onze h, trinta, meia noite, geralmente beleza. Então a primeira coisa é o repositório. Eu deixei ele aberto essa semana. Ele Vai Ser Fechado Eu Deixei Pra Ficar Mais simples Pra Gente Poder Trabalhar Senão Eu Teria Que Adicionar Todo Mundo.
E assim por diante, tá? Então ele está atualizado.
Ele tem basicamente tudo. E a gente vai começar com a ideia de um Brownfield. Eu adoro isso.
O que a ideia de um Brown Field para um Greenfield. O Greenfield é um ambiente que a gente vai começar do zero.
A gente não vai começar do zero aqui. Porque, de acordo com o sistema, o sistema já roda hoje numa Pipeline A Gente Vai Construir Uma Pipeline Moderna.
Ao longo.
Não pode ter dado quatrocentos e quatro.
Só se caiu.
Só se caiu o Guit.
Porque, Ah, não? Calma aí.
Oi. Eu tinha tirado.
Deixa eu mudar aqui. Só um minutinho.
Está privado.
Which a tirar das outras.
Tinha esquecido essa. Então.
Mandar de novo aqui. Pronto, acho que agora vocês dão refresh. Aí vocês vão conseguir ver.
Isso aqui não é do. é, foi.
Botei o do cliente, na verdade, né.
Beleza. Então acho que todo mundo agora tem acesso, né?
A gente vai navegar durante essa semana. A gente vai entender.
Pedaço desse repositório. Então fiquem tranquilos.
Vamos prestar atenção no processo como um todo e a gente vai navegar nele.
Beleza. Então todo mundo aí consegue acessar esse cara.
Recomendo vocês fazerem um foque para o ambiente de vocês. A gente vai dar uma olhadinha nisso também.
Mas.
Nada. Tipo Request aqui, faz um Fork pessoal e trabalha com ele.
Pessoal. Vocês vão depender de mim. Eu não quero que vocês dependam de mim. Não tá.
Espera um minutinho aí. Que pode ser.
Já tiveram trinta e três focos. Tá João.
São a questão de.
Acho que não tenha passado. Api beleza.
O Forken aí.
Traga para vocês que a gente vai trabalhar essa semana. Bom que cada um trabalha completamente independente. A gente vai Coletando Vai Fazendo Harvest.
Disso. Aí tá.
Bem, primeira coisa, então, fazer o forking trazer para o seu ambiente local.
Beleza. E daí? A gente vai tudo que vai acontecer de forma prática aqui. Ela vai estar no Run.
Então ela vai estar aqui dentro do Run.
Que a gente vai executando, passo a passo aqui, cada um desses processos. Então, todo dia vocês vão ver uma pasta.
Com tudo que a gente vai executar.
Beleza e uma explicação exatamente do que a gente vai executar, do que por que e assim por diante.
Então a gente vai passar aqui um a.
A primeira coisa que eu escolhi para a gente fazer.
Foi instalado o Mypie. Mas na verdade, é basicamente o ambiente como um todo que a gente vai instalar. E Daí Você Vai Instalar Seu Vs Code Com O Codec A Gente Vai Configurar Esse Cara.
Eu vou mostrar rapidamente aqui como se a gente estivesse começando do zero, né?
Por que que você preferiu on my Pie.
Tá de novo. Vocês podem usar o que vocês quiserem. Tá bom. A ideia de utilizar o One é porque Você Tem A Capacidade De Integrar Suas Assinaturas Mas Não Somente Isso.
Você tem a capacidade de conseguir.
Usar, por exemplo, o Open router, colocar um crédito lá dentro e utilizar bastante de psique.
Ou qualquer outro modelo Minimax tem alguns modelos bem interessantes para usar.
Inclusive eu. Não sei se vocês viram esse último modelo. O X Alpha, que foi lançado ontem.
Que ainda está em Stealth Mode.
Mas surpreendente. Inclusive estão dizendo que é o melhor modelo do mundo.
Pelos testes que eu fiz aqui. Realmente.
Desculpetiva. O modelo tá.
Testei ele com codebase complexo. Testei ele para a criação de.
De de Boilerplate.
Para a criação de apresentação.
Para investigação de Bytebit com Cobal Overpunch. Ele pegou tudo.
Então. Bem interessante. Esse Oxalfa.
Não sei se vocês viram, né? Muita gente.
Está explodindo no X. Os caras simplesmente são stealth Mode.
E hoje no Open Router. Um milhão de tokens está de graça.
Até um milhão de Tokens está. Free, você não paga, tá.
Então vocês quiserem dar uma testadinha nele.
Sinistro. Bem, bem, bem.
Sinistro. Tá.
Gostei bastante.
Olá. Ele deixa o Fable no chinelo. Tipo isso.
é sinistro, caro, que o que eles conseguem fazer agora é testar literalmente no ambiente. Mas se a gente for olhar, por exemplo.
Sobre o que ele consegue fazer. Ele bateu oitenta.
Em níveis de tarefa complexa onde o Feibble bateu sessenta e cinco.
down pay.
Eu possamente que es nao gosto de vending machines. Eu molhadamas essen premi.
OFS.
com.
que.
J' a thing on de toquens outrelesados entreis dias.
flash domain. O sin.
Uh, sinister.
Então. Muito bom. Bem, interessante.
Aqui está o link do repositório.
Então vamos lá. Vamos em Run.
E aí, gente, vamos comentando comigo. Como tá indo? Você está conseguindo executar assim por diante, tá? Eu quero ver aqui.
De um on my pai.
Provavelmente a maioria das pessoas já tem suscetado, mas a gente vai cetar aqui. Então eu vou entrar dentro do On Mypie Sch.
O homem, pai é um multiharness.
A gente vai ver o que que isso significa. Ele não é só um Harness para o Cloud. Ele não é Só Um Harness Para O Gpt Ele é Um Harness Para Qualquer Harness Inclusive Tá.
Então ele tem um hardness em cima disso.
O que torna mais complexo. E às vezes, pode trazer algumas dores de cabeça.
Mas o Harness do homem Pie é muito bom, tá? Todos que eu conheço.
Ele. Eu acredito que ele é o melhor Harness que eu já testei. Multi Harness que eu já testei.
O que seria um multiharness ali no mercado. A gente tem um pai. A gente tem um Omni Agents da Data Brics.
A gente tem o Mypie. Existem alguns outros também, tá? E cada vez mais a gente vai acabar vendo um Pouquinho Disso Também O Opencode.
Mas eu gosto muito dele. Por ser minimalista, eficiente, muito fácil de trabalhar. Existem vários features legais nele.
Então, basicamente, a gente vai instalar ele. Você pode instalar ele no Windows. Você pode instalar ele no Mac.
Tem via pause shell, então, sim, você pode estar lá em qualquer lugar, por isso.
A ideia de estar.
Então, macos blue macos. Se você quiser trabalhar com Powershell, tem no Windows. Tá pra você instalar.
Então, sem problema algum. Então, basicamente, você vai instalar esse cara.
E aí, o que você vai ter aqui?
Eu vou abrir aqui uma nova aba que eu estou utilizando cimax.
Mas pode ser qualquer ambiente que você tenha. C h, tá.
Então eu vou colocar um Mypie Op.
Porque eu já instalei esse cara.
Deixa eu só dar, na verdade, um Exit aqui que eu quero dar um up update finalmente para atualizar a última Versão Do Op Então Eu Vou Atualizar Ele Aqui.
Você. Se você quiser utilizar o Womp.
Você vai utilizar esse cara aqui? Instalação dele.
Eu estou atualizando o meu.
E aí a primeira parte da nossa.
Nosso rolê é instalar ele, né.
Down on My One Might Opie.
Esse é o primeiro cara.
Acho que não precisa isolar o ambiente. Não, você vai dentro do ambiente. Você vai criar um ven, algo desse Tipo Que Vai Fazer Automaticamente Mas.
Só se você quiser mesmo. Tá, Lucas?
Nesse caso.
Não vejo nada que quebraria.
She isolar o ambiente completamente. Não.
Tu podes fazer isso. Você pode fazer isso com uma Walk Tree, por exemplo.
Beleza. Então, no final do dia, você tem que conseguir fazer op.
Né.
Não tem problema se não conseguir, não tá. Você pode usar overse code. Qualquer um.
Não tem problema. Não tá? Então aqui a gente vai.
Em Setup. Aí, basicamente, ele vai abrir isso aqui para você.
E aí a primeira coisa que ele faz tá.
é você conectar a assinatura.
A sua assinatura. Então eu conectei aqui meu chat Ept. Conectei meu Kim. Conectei meu open router.
Conectei meu groc.
Conectei.
Mas o quê? Tem várias né de psique.
Api que eu pego direto de psique.
Outra coisa. Tavli, hexa.
Otwo X. Eu não sei se vocês conhecem, mas cara para mim, é algo.
Na minha opinião, obrigatório de ter.
Ou um ou outro mais obrigatório.
Otavenir. Eu já uso muito tempo os dois. Tá.
O Taville. Na verdade, o que ele é, né?
Ele conecta o seu agente pela via Internet. Então você tem vários créditos.
Bem razoáveis no free cheer.
Então você pode utilizar ele.
E aí você basicamente pede para utilizar ele ou para pesquisar na web, e ele faz esse bridge para você.
A mesma coisa que o hexa, tá? O hexa na mesma pegada também para você fazer pesquisa.
E aí você pergunta pra mim o seguinte, tá, mas por que dois, né?
Bem, até mais. às vezes eu uso muito Firecrow também. Fire Crow tem uma capacidade muito legal que o Table E O Hexa Não Faz Tão Bem Que Ele Consegue Raspar.
Páginas e sub páginas. Ele consegue raspar certos conteúdos que.
O Table e o Hexan não faz. Então, quando eu quero fazer uma Deep Research, por exemplo.
Eu uso os dois. Beleza.
Mas tá aqui. Então você vai.
Basicamente conectar com a sua assinatura.
E aí setup completo. Teoricamente, você vai dar um barra aqui. Você pode ir em Model.
E aí você vai ver a lista dos modelos que você tem aqui, né?
De psique. Eu tenho cara. O pró e o Flash.
Aqui no Kimi. Eu tenho o Química. Tres um milhão de parâmetros.
Eu tenho.
Openai Codecs aqui, né? Sol, terra e Luna.
Tem o X ai.
O Grok quatro seis e o quatro sete lança na semana que vem. Se eu não estou enganado.
E a gente tem o Open Router.
Quatrocentos e setenta modelos disponíveis. Olha só. Que legal.
O Stealth. Ox Alpha.
Ele está a um milhão. Frio. Está vendo?
Você não paga por ele por um milhão de tokens.
Beleza.
E aí eu tenho algumas formas de como eu deixo ele características. Eu posso ter ele como.
Um cara para planejar. Eu postei ele como um advisor. Isso é muito legal do. Oh, my Pie.
Que não só você tem um modelo como um todo, mas você também pode ter.
Esse conceito de Rolls, né?
Então, por exemplo, se a gente vier aqui em cima, Rose All. Tá vendo?
Eu tenho vários Rolls aqui.
Eu tenho um road planner de designer.
De task de advisor. E isso aqui é legal. Você pode criar sua própria roll.
Então o que você pode fazer? Vamos supor que você quer um plan. Então você vai citar esse plano aqui Para Ser Um Gpt Soul.
Por exemplo. Tá.
Depois pô, eu quero um cara para ser um advisor.
Tá? Eu vou, cara. Mandar um Fable cinco aqui. Claro, você não vai fazer isso. Mas enfim.
Tá? E daí você vai ter esse cara. Você pode planejar. E na hora que você está trabalhando, você vai Chamando Esses Agentes Aqui.
Isso é uma coisa muito legal que facilita o dia absurdamente por estar dentro do mesmo Harmess. Tá.
Então você não precisa navegar, fazer o swing by entre vários modelos.
Beleza. Então eu estou aqui.
Eu estou conectado. Não estou conectado no repositório. Então eu vou sair aqui para conectar no repositório.
Então eu vou no meio ambiente, dar um Cd.
Entrar na minha pasta de Github.
Dá um Cd aqui a gente vai no use. Case o C. Northwind.
Bem. E aqui eu vou dar um homem, Pie. Eu vou entrar dentro do contexto do Projeto Beleza. Agora que Estou Dentro Do Contexto Do Projeto.
Na mãe. Ele leu tudo isso aqui.
E aí eu posso simplesmente. Eu já estou pronto para poder.
Trabalhar com esse cara.
Se você quer. E provavelmente é poxa, eu não tenho nenhum tipo de ambiente para poder trabalhar. Enfim, me avisa que.
That was. Acredito que todo mundo tenha.
Que aí a gente concede uma chave do Open router para você poder conectar e usar durante a semana. Mas, Pelo Amor De Deus Só Quem Não Tem Né.
Quem tem? Não me peça, obviamente.
Você acredita que todo mundo aqui tem uma assinatura, inclusive.
Eu acho que o Augusto falou que tem uma assinatura do anti Gravit que está saindo do Jam Nine pro.
Que está saindo? Por quanto, Augusto? Eu não sei. Você tem um link aí.
Que é extremamente barata, inclusive eu não fiz ela. E eu acho que cara me mandei o link para eu fazer.
Noventa e sete por mês.
O Geminife pro dezoito menos noventa e sete. Não, calma aí. Até eu vou assinar isso. Aí.
Beleza. Se quem quiser passar o link pra ir pra eu assinar aqui, eu agradeço. Tá.
Rapaz, acredito. Não, deixa eu ver.
Jim Nai Pro por dezoito meses sem pagar o preço.
Garantir meu acesso noventa e sete.
Depois eu faço. Caraca. Funciona mesmo. Então, ó, tem o Google Students também.
Google Gemini. Um ano grátis no plano para estudantes do Geminai. Faz gratuito resgate.
Legal. Beleza.
Então o Open Router.
E aqui no caso, eu vou utilizar o super end newing para fazer esse.
Esse hook.
Aí você pode utilizar o Orca, o Orca. Eu gosto do Orca.
Eu já usei orca.
O Kiro é legal. O Orc é legal. Tem um que muitas poucas pessoas conhecem. Eu já usei. Já usei bastante.
Eu gosto bastante dele. Ele tem um look in film maravilhoso que é o Sinara.
Tá? é outro cara muito legal de ter.
Mas ele só tem pra Match. Ele é bem interessante. Ele tem parte de thread. Ele tem parte de Cambán. Ele Tem Umas Coisas Bem Legais Também O Look And Feel Dele.
Parece o Codex.
Sinara, você tem o orca que se eu não me engano, ele é disponível em todas as plataformas.
Você tem o Orc aqui.
Beleza que é muito bom. Você tem o Kiro, que é muito bom também. Ele já tem Speciven Development embedado nele.
Boa. Também existem vários outros lá. Tá.
Eu vou utilizar o super engineering.
Porque eu sou completamente apaixonado pelo Super Engineering.
Então vou trazer o super engineering aqui.
Esse é o Super Engineering.
Uma das coisas.
The Guys aqui do Super Engineering é que você pode vir aqui embaixo na parte de experimental.
E tem várias coisas experimentais, principalmente que eles lançaram hoje, que é o automation. Você pode criar automações dentro.
Da China. Ele tem Age Orchestration pela cela. Ele consegue orquestrar vários engines.
E uma das coisas que são muito legais é que se você for em Agents, por exemplo.
Você consegue configurar? Quais são os sistemas que você quer? Qual Harness que você quer conectar?
Então vejam aqui que ele tem Groc. Que ele tem. Codex cursor.
Ele tem tudo. Basicamente, Open Code Kim antigravity.
Ele tem toda parada.
E aí? Nesse caso, como ele tem o My Pie. Então, o que eu faço quando eu venho aqui no. Oh, my Pie.
Ele está conectado no meu online, Pie. Então eu instalei. Pie configurei ele. Ele está conectado com o meu online.
Então aqui. ó, eu já tenho todas aquelas assinaturas. Quando entro no My Pie aqui tá tudo aqui.
Todas de Open router. Está vendo todas que são do Kimi, por exemplo, de psique.
And. Elas aparecem aqui. Cláudio Opus. E daí vem toda a parte de.
Open router aqui que a gente tem. Então eu posso utilizar vários modelos.
E posso utilizar os barra comends dele também.
Para poder chamar.
Ali. O que eu quero? Beleza.
Eu tenho tudo disponível aqui para mim.
That is aí aqui. Se eu quero entrar no projeto, eu venho aqui em Ad Project.
At existing.
E daí? Eu vou obviamente pegar o projeto que eu fiz. O Forking.
Nesse caso, o senhor Film de pay.
Beleza. E mais o quê? Ah, uma coisa que a gente vai trabalhar bastante também. Org.
Tá, que é uma coisa legal de vocês trabalharem para criar um ambiente completamente isolado dele.
E é isso.
O Harness do super Engineering não conflita com o Mypye. Não, né?
Até porque o Harness, por eles terem uma ideia agêntica. Basicamente, ele tem um Finlayer muito pequeno. Só se você Realmente Invocar Esse Cara Pelo Sc Que é O Superconductor.
Work Tree é usado para você não conflitar atividades entre agentes. Então, por exemplo.
Eu evito muito criar Brent.
Bastante. Por exemplo, quando eu estou trabalhando em duas coisas diferentes. Dentro do repositório, eu evito criar Brand, porque.
Porque o agente pode roubar de um contexto para o outro. Ele pode mudar entre as Brings.
Então a ideia é que, por exemplo, eu quero implementar alguma coisa completamente isolada. Então você vem aqui, cria um novo Org Tree.
A gente vai fazer isso. Aí ele cria um novo walk trick completamente isolado. Ele copia isso aqui. Cola, e Você Tem Um Agente Completamente Separado.
E você pode ter vários work thirties. Então é um ambiente muito legal.
Depois você manda um pull requests.
E está tudo certo. Beleza.
Então, beleza. Configuramos o Mypye ou qualquer ambiente que vocês quiserem de Harness.
Citamos literalmente o Workspace que a gente vai trabalhar.
E agora a gente precisa validar essas três coisas que a gente vai utilizar aqui, tá.
Então Gee.
Docker e Python.
é o que você tem que ter para conseguir rodar esse ambiente.
Gitch, Dock e Python. Basicamente.
Busy Show, que está disponível para qualquer um, tá.
Então deve estar tranquilo para vocês aí eu acredito, né.
E Aí A Gente Vai Usar O Git Justamente Para Poder Fazer Cloning O Docker Para Poder Subir Toda A infraestrutura. Isso é uma outra recomendação que hoje, qualquer um que você trabalhe com sistemas agênticos. Obviamente, isso sempre foi uma melhor prática para engenheiros de software.
Não tanto para engenheiros de dados, porque a gente geralmente não conseguia buildar tudo.
Mas é sempre, se você puder. Com todas as certezas, tem um ambiente de deve local.
Principalmente com sistemas agênticos. Agora você quer ter literalmente a garantia que essas coisas funcionam dentro de Dockers containizados. Você consegue trabalhar rápido.
Você consegue tirar muito rápido. E daí? Você consegue puxar esses caras para cima.
Depois ouvia Kubernetes. Ouvia terraforma. Você pode escolher.
Exatamente o que você quer. Uma das coisas que a gente rouba bastante, né?
Do time de infraestrutura da galera de infraestrutura. é o Make.
O make. é algo que assim.
Eu lembro quando eu conheci o Make.
Ela simplesmente entra em paixão severa com ele.
Hoje. Tudo que eu faço.
Em todos os repositórios. Tem make? Então a gente vai ver o que o Make é.
Basicamente, ele é só uma camada que chama várias coisas para a gente. Vários scripts para você não ter que memorizar.
Sequências de scripts e assim por diante. Eu dou um making it.
Ele inicializa o projeto todo. Meio que deploy. Ele faz de plant do Doc. Faz configuração valida. Enfim.
Então é um comando que encapsula.
é uma sequência de scripts. Shell.
E o Python, obviamente, Python, como linguagem, como a gente.
Como engenheiros, como engenheiros de software, a gente vai utilizar Python all the way through.
Para poder fazer tradução de Java para poder fazer deployment, para poder fazer.
Para poder. Pipelines and it shows. Esses quatro kits aqui.
Beleza. Bem, agora vem a grande. Acho que a grande sacada, né?
Se a gente for parar para pensar.
Construir uma fábrica agêntica.
Vai demorar para você? Meses, meses e meses e meses de trabalho.
Por vários motivos. Primeiro, porque você precisa eventualmente.
De executar em diversos llms hoje.
Segundo, porque você precisa.
Ter a capacidade de entender aonde você vai escrever. O que você vai escrever. Você precisa dividir o sistema de Uma Forma Que Você Possa.
Trabalhar em Work Tries separados ou em ambientes completamente separados. Por exemplo, o front end.
Do back end da engenharia. Enfim, só que você não pode, muitas das vezes, dividir dessa forma.
Porque existe um conflito hierárquico entre elas. Então, muitas das vezes você tem que decompor.
Essa quebra de uma forma um pouquinho diferente, tá.
E a ideia a gente ter uma espinha que conecta tudo isso. Então.
De forma exclusiva para vocês. Essa semana.
Esses quatro projetos estarão abertos para vocês poderem usar, fazer o download e utilizar. Eu não ia dar disponível para vocês. O converge.
Mas se a gente não colocasse o converge aqui essa semana.
A gente não conseguiria criar uma fábrica no Prompt. A gente não conseguiria criar uma fábrica com processo.
Então a ideia é que a gente vai passar por esses três projetos e o quarto? Na verdade, o Brief Spec Para Quem Quiser Utilizar.
Mas basicamente, a gente vai utilizar um Framework, o Framework que eu criei ao longo desses meses, trabalhando.
Para padronizar as coisas.
Então, começando pelo Test Spec, o Task Spec. O que ele faz na verdade.
Ele trabalhará no nível folha ou no nível atômico da tarefa. Então.
Ele recebe um requisito. Ele transforma aquele requisito numa tarefa autônoma. Então a gente vai ver isso em detalhe ao Longo Dos Dias Tá.
O. Sim, Wise. é uma forma de como eu vou decompor o problema.
Então imagina que eu tenho uma série de coisas para fazer dentro de um repositório como aqui.
Pô. A gente vai levantar requisito. A gente vai traduzir Java. A gente vai criar a pipeline de dados.
A gente vai entregar a informação na Gold.
Por ajuai por fast Api e Mcps.
A gente vai trabalhar a parte de a engineering para ter base para ter camada de ontologia e assim por diante.
Como que eu consigo dentro desse code base inteiro.
Trabalhar diferentes vertentes e vértices disso, sem quebrar e trabalhar isso de forma eficiente.
Então, sim, Wise faz isso. Ele recebe o problema e ele consegue cortar o sistema de uma forma em que A Gente Possa Trabalhar.
De uma forma mais segregada e separada e eficiente.
E o converge. é a espinha que vai conectar tudo isso.
E intenco.
El tenosuo momentemcao em fabrica.
Vela premier vesos es um vezo equita, ning de envivi sauces.
Na.
semen.
Vou passar. Eu vou utilizar ele durante a semana.
Eu não vou explicar ele durante a semana. Existem duas coisas. Eu vou dar um briefing. Do que é.
Deuticamente. Thomas, eu teria outras sessões aí eu vou ter um booticamp só para falar.
De converge, na verdade, tá construção. E o que acontece por debaixo deles?
Então deixa eu passar aqui oito linhas, né? Oito passes.
Então o primeiro passo é capturar a informação. Segundo, é capturar intenção.
Depois eu vou estruturar esses arquivos. Depois eu vou decompor. Utilizando assim Wise.
Depois eu vou utilizar várias llms para fazer um plano adversarial e a gente chegar no mesmo.
Embate. Fechar cem com a Indigning.
Então, até aqui, do pes zero ao pesquatro. Eu chamo isso de Human in the Loop. O Human Gate.
Aqui o humano interage. Então, até aqui, você tem o humano interagindo.
Depois disso. Aqui tem uma quebra em que eu saio da parte humana. E eu vou para a parte máquina. Então Fecha Um Contrato Do Ser Humano Com A Máquina.
E daqui toda outra parte. Ela é cem autônoma. Então pô.
Gerei o plano. Decompus, entendeu? é isso mesmo. As Lms concordaram. Concordo com o plano. é isso.
Daí, ele vai quebrar essas informações em níveis atômicos, que é tarefas mínimas.
Ele vai registrar isso. Ele pode registrar isso no repositório. Ele pode registrar isso no linear.
Daí ele vai fazer o binding. Ele vai assinalar as engines que eu quero executar. Ele vai criar um loop Que Ele Fica Movendo Todas As Atividades A Gente Vai Ver Isso Lá No último Dia No Penúltimo E No último Dia.
Ele pega as tarefas e vai movendo.
Do status que está, sei lá, Pending, em Progress.
E, por exemplo, complete. Então ele vai trabalhando todas as tarefas e executando como se fosse uma fábrica.
Como se fosse uma fábrica de luz apagada.
Então a gente vai ver esses três componentes ao longo.
Né da semana. E o Brief Spec, para quem quiser utilizar o Brief Spec. é um projeto.
Aonde a gente tem basicamente.
Forma de como a gente vai ler da Llm, como a gente trabalha com várias llms hoje.
Então é difícil você ter uma forma com que a Llm cospe a informação para você.
Então o Brief Spec nada mais é do que a forma como a informação para você e como você lê.
Então ele tem várias técnicas ali. De como ele entrega a informação.
Que Llm escreveu para você.
Então é como se ela tivesse o que a gente chama de Post Hook.
Então, na hora que ele lm cospe.
Eu intercepto essa cuspida da Llm. E eu organizo e deixo ela bonitinha, formatada para poder ler.
Como eu uso vários llms. Eu crio um padrão. Eu não tenho mais gasto cognitivo de tentar entender o que O Opus Cuspiu Feio.
Como o Deep se cuspiu de uma forma.
Como que o Feibal cuspiu de outro, como que o sol cuspiu de outro. Enfim, eu tenho vontade.
Um padrão de interface. é uma interface de leitura. Basicamente, tá.
Antes eu começar todo mundo comigo. Faz sentido. Coloca aí. Temos cento e cinquenta e dois pessoas.
Sim, faz sentido.
Se a gente como eu falei. Se a gente tentasse construir a fábrica inteira sem padrão, sem framework.
Sem design, Pattern. Impossível de fazer isso numa semana.
é impossível, realmente. Então a gente vai utilizar.
Padrões de processos para poder fazer isso. Beleza.
Tá? Então vamos começar a literalmente botar fogo no parquinho. Aí.
Entender o processo Full Circle que a gente vai passar, né?
A gente fez a parte de um boarding. A gente vai dar uma olhadinha agora no processo como um todo. Depois A Gente, Vai Entrar No Processo Do Arqueologista Que é.
Como eu tá? Entro nesse conceito nesse contexto, e entendo como um tudo.
Luan. Só para esclarecer. Então, a semana genica foi mais para passar o conteúdo e mostrar a teoria como um Pouco De Prática A Ideia Do Booticamp Então é Por Prática Step A Step Tudo Aquilo Que Aprendemos Lá.
E mais, exatamente. Então a semana é para dar uma visão assim bem grande do que é louco, do que é Harness Do Que é Evol Do Que é.
Do que é, Graph. Como que a gente usa os componentes. Enfim.
E aqui a gente vai ver isso na prática, no caso de uso. E a gente vai navegar a ter Uma Fábrica Autônoma Tá.
Então a ideia é consolidar tudo.
Beleza. Então a semana serve muito para dar essa intro.
E depois a gente vai entrar aqui, tá?
Hey, são estímulos de aula diferentes, né, pessoal? Até porque a gente tinha trezentos e tantas pessoas. Então é diferente E Tal, né? O Booticamp Agora Nas Novas Propostas Aqui Do Acari Do Plumbers Enfim.
A gente vai fazer como cohorts. Então vão ter limite de cento e cinquenta pessoas por turma.
Então não passa disso, porque senão eu não consigo. E a ideia é a gente ir tirando dúvida, quebrando no Outro Dia Pô Chegando Um Pouco Mais Cedo Tentando Resolver E Assim Por Diante.
Testando. Então, cara, vai ser muito bom. Estou muito empolgado para esse Budicamp. Para ser bem honesto.
Porque como eu sei que cada um vai usar um Llm diferente, a gente vai ter um teste muito foda, Tá Aqui Vai Ser Bem Legal Isso é Uma Experiência Que Todo Mundo Vai Poder Consumir.
O que o ambiente já roda. A gente está entrando num Brown field. é um ambiente que já existe.
E sendo bem honesto para vocês.
Se vocês forem olhar no espectro de um sênior.
Ou de um arquiteto ou de um lead.
Cara. Muitas das vezes, vocês vão entrar em projetos que já existem. Vocês vão fazer migração de coisas que já Existem Outra Coisa Que Eu Vou Falar Para Vocês Que.
Está acontecendo assim fora do país. Eu não sei se vocês já estão passando aí.
Outro ambiente legal para vocês compartilharem. Vocês já estão passando por migração de sistemas para modernização. Eu sei que modernização Já Existe Há Muitos Anos.
Está modernizando um prêmios para ir para a nuvem assim por diante. Mas quem aqui está passando um projeto de Modernização De Migração De Tecnologias De Um Lado Para O Outro Cara.
Essa fábrica aqui. Ela funciona.
Completamente. Ela foi criada. Uma das vértices dela foi criada exatamente para isso.
Para fazer migrações, por exemplo.
Então é pô migração de Big Crowd pra Data Brics de Databrics para isso, não, Flake de Aws para.
égio de égio para a Gcp or Whatever.
De Python para Goal.
Né? Então assim.
O que a gente vai ver é que a fábrica é canônica. Então, se não conseguir utilizar qualquer tipo de Coisa Que Você Queira.
O que hoje funciona no ambiente.
The North Windpay. O que a gente tem aqui, né?
Então a gente tem hoje funcionando um Sftp.
Que tem um dado cru.
Daí. A gente tem o Java que vai fazer o Parsing Sanitizar esse dado.
Vai verificar se essa informação que chegou do Sftp.
Está de acordo com o contrato que foi estabelecido entre eles.
Posteriormente. Depois, a gente tem.
Esse dado, sendo inscrito num Csv.
Então o Java pega esse cara por ser uma aplicação já alegada com muitos anos. A gente está falando de Dez quinze Anos De Aplicação Que Já Funcionando.
Estado. Escreve no Csv.
Depois a gente tem um processo lá no Postcurs que vai, conecta nesse Sftp.
E traz esse dado para dentro da área de Staging.
Do pushy. Faz um copying into staging.
Para que literalmente, o Loader, que é o cara que carrega. Nunca vejo dado Raw. Ele vai ver somente o dado depois.
Do Sftp lá do Incoming.
Aí. A gente tem as Store. Procedures que vão aplicar as lógicas no Batch.
Depois a gente tem os relatórios que acontecem em relação a isso. Então os times ali Stop procedures que validam.
Fazem o refresh da informação. Vê o que vai ser. Charge back. O que é settlement? Avaliar.
Cartão e assim por diante.
E no final, a gente tem o Judge, que é o Oráculo.
Isso aqui é uma coisa interessante. O Oráculo que eu trouxe para vocês é qualquer tipo de identificação do que significa, certo?
E isso é uma das coisas muito importantes para um Llm.
Você tem a entrada.
Muita gente tem entrada e não tem meio. Nem tem a saída.
Cara. Você nunca vai conseguir dizer que o M llm. Ela funcionou cem. Se você não tiver saída, nunca.
Agora, se você tiver entrado e você tiver a saída.
O que está no meio, que é uma fábrica, independentemente do que você esteja fazendo.
Você consegue chegar no resultado final.
Muito bem, se você tiver isso, então a primeira coisa que você vai fazer num projeto que você está começando, é.
Qual é a definição do que é certo?
O que que realmente é. O resultado final.
Então, cara, se o cliente hoje, por exemplo, tem um Snowflake.
Ele recebe lá. Arquivo Csv.
Ele processa no Snowflake. E no final, tem uma tabela lá que diz que usuário um ganhou cem reais.
Esse é o seu Golden Match. Esse é o seu Oráculo, né?
Esse é seu dataset escrito por Deus.
Varias.
coerte.
Vo fazio bochendo systema.
E ele vai verificar se está tudo. Healthy, o que a gente quer entender?
é que toda parte do ambiente eu vou chamar ele de ambiente legado, porque a gente vai transformar ele para Um Ambiente Moderno Né.
Eu temo basicamente as entradas de cadao de responsonan coatamente, um temo super usuario.
estomita muita trellado.
There, as informa is eu gio feis um face mont interlecent.
Po dos muchivos.
Eh.
Legadas e assim por diante. O mais utilizado.
Indiscutivelmente. E segundo, porque eu não entendo porra nenhuma de Java.
E essa é a grande ideia do treinamento.
Você não precisa saber. Java para escrever esses termos agênticos.
Muito bem, então.
Como que a gente sem ser engenheiro de software, vai conseguir entender. E pior, traduzir que é o pior ainda.
Então.
A grande ideia. Eu não sei nem para onde vai. Eu olho e falo. Pô legal. Entendi aqui. Mas bota Para Escrever Nunca Conseguiria Na Minha Vida Morreria Aqui.
Para quem já entende, Java, que bom para quem não entende. Java foi feito para você o treinamento. Porque eu Sou Um Animal De Teta Que Também Não Sei Java.
Então fiquem tranquilos, tá?
A ideia é para vocês. Até não entenderem que nem eu entrei num projeto que os caras escreviam em.
Qual era o nome? Kolkling.
Eu falei, cara what the fuck is Cooking. Eu nem sei, eu juro. Nem sabia o que era Coldlin.
Mas no final das contas, tanto faz. Você aprende os abstractos. Você aprende os design, Patterns.
Você trabalha juntamente com a Llm. Você valida e assim por diante.
E daí? Você faz o processo.
Eu não aprendi Java na faculdade porque eu não formei, então achei me.
Então realmente eu não tive a oportunidade de aprender java, né?
Man. Não sei se é oportunidade, enfim, mas.
Eu acredito que quanto mais conhecimento você tem, melhor. Então, se você sabe, Java muito melhor para você.
A chances de você fazer isso muito melhor. Não perdeu nada.
Vai ser muito melhor. Tá.
Beleza. Então, por causa disso.
Java, porque é complexo da gente entender realmente, principalmente vestindo os hatzinhos de engenheiro de dados.
Outra Coisa A Gente Vai Rodar Uma Steel Thread Que Eu Vou Falar Basicamente Qual é A Grande Ideia Mas a gente tem um Make run aqui para rodar os cenários. Então lembra que eu falei pra vocês que durante essa semana nós iremos ver cinco cenários.
E cinco cenários. Na verdade, são cinco tipos diferentes de arquivos.
O primeiro arquivo que a gente está trabalhando literalmente.
é o arquivo de Cards. Então a gente vai ter um entendimento desse tipo.
O que significa esse cara.
Então a gente vai validar ele. Então eu tenho um make aqui.
Que basicamente, o que vai fazer? Ele vai gerar um Bet.
Ele vai trazer esse arquivo de settlement que a gente vai ver. A gente vai ver qual o valor final Dele De Cento E Setenta E Três Quarenta E Cinco.
Ele vai gerar duas rows de Detail, que vai ser a soma deles. Protecentos e setenta e três quarenta e cinco.
Ele vai ter um status de sucesso para a gente ver literalmente que esse processo rodou de fim a fim.
é um teste que a gente vai fazer. Beleza.
O que acontece quando a gente executa aquele Batch. Isso é uma outra coisa interessante.
Uma das coisas que você vai fazer.
E eu recomendo muito que você faça nos projetos nos seus projetos.
é criar dados sintéticos cada vez isso mais se torna importante, porque.
Porque muitas das vezes o cliente não vai ou nos seus ambientes de Dev para Prod, você não vai ter Acesso A Um Ambiente De Produção.
Mas o que você pode ter com certeza é acesso ao quê? Ao meta, dado.
O metadado muitas das vezes é disponível para você.
Então o cara pode gerar ali o métodado da tabela.
E ele pode inclusive te passar quinze registros ali, talvez. Ou pode passar pelo menos uma explicação do que cada campo significa.
Uma vez com isso, você gera um gerador de dados sintéticos.
é engraçado, mas muitas empresas não possuem isso. E eu recomendo muito para começar.
Quando você desenvolve. Quando você vai criar qualquer projeto do seu lado?
Desenvolver um gerador de dados sintéticos. Cara, isso ajuda.
Largamente, não seu processo de desenvolvimento.
Mas ele ajuda em uma coisa que, para mim, era uma dor de cabeça.
Quando eu trabalhava com engenharia de dados. Realmente, Roots.
Que era fazer. Smoke tests.
Isso me dava uma dor de cabeça tão grande.
O que é o Smoke Test? é literalmente fazer um teste de fumaça, verificar como que o ambiente se comporta em determinadas características.
Então pô. Como que ele se comportam quando eu faço upload de um arquivo.
Quando ele se comporta. Quando eu faço upload de o tipo um e o tipo dois.
Como ele se comporta. Quando eu faço, por exemplo, o upload de cem arquivos ao mesmo tempo.
Como ele se comporta. Se eu injetar um erro no meio do arquivo.
Como ele se comporta. Se eu corromper um arquivo.
Então isso gera uma capacidade sua de conseguir estar preparado para a produção muito grande.
E tudo começa na minha humilde opinião como gerador de dados sintéticos. Então, assim.
Invista nem geradores de dados sintéticos. Sempre que você pode, tá sempre para todo projeto.
Que gerador de dados sintéticos. Ainda mais hoje, com o Llm. Então fica extremamente ridículo de você fazer isso.
Hey, ou só botar? Wilker tem um ponto.
And só botar no usuário também. Que ele consegue inclusive quebrar tudo que você fez de uma forma magnífica que Você Fala Caraca Velho.
Eu testei tudo. Até o Qll me falou o usuário. Cinco minutos, ó, deu problema aqui.
Sim, já tem uma cela, obviamente para isso. Então a ideia é vocês criarem os Celi de vocês e encapsularem No Processo Né A Gente Tem Aqui Também.
Então a ideia é a gente ter essa Cia like, projeto.
Então a gente vai ter um gerador de dados, né? Ele vai fazer a publicação desse arquivo lá no Raw Incoming Lá No Sftp.
Daí. A gente vai ter o inta.
Dessa informação. A gente vai receber essa informação lá.
Daí a gente vai ter o Java, né?
Literalmente traduzindo esse arquivo. Pegando essa informação.
Carregando via né, Copy para dentro do postrest.
A procedure, aplicando o refreshing dos relatórios. Enfim.
E o Oráculo, validando se aquele valor era esperado para aquele tipo de resultado.
Então, basicamente, é isso que acontece.
Pois, basta os panos. Quando a gente roda o Make Run ali para executar um caso de uso. E a Gente Vai Fazer Isso Para Todos Os Casos De Uso Que A Gente Vai Trabalhar.
Então agora a gente vai começar a navegar um pouquinho no processo de boating e de criação e de execução Como Um Todo Para Verificar Se A Gente, Consegue Todo Mundo Aqui Consegue Chegar No Mesmo Resultado.
Ser super legal. Então vamos lá.
Vamos aqui no Boot, no cinco.
Então aqui a gente vai fazer o Git clone vai entrar dentro do repositório.
E a gente ia fazer um making it. Um make deploy.
Então a gente vai vir aqui no Repositório.
Eu vou abrir aqui um terminal.
Dentro do Hippo.
Eu vou dar um making it.
Eu vou verificar se está tudo certo.
Eu quero que vocês façam também. A ideia é que todo mundo consiga chegar.
Ou não. Vamos ver aí como vocês vão resolver.
Até porque isso aqui não é um copia e cola. é dinâmico. Cada um vai trabalhar de uma forma. A Gente Vai Resolver Como Time.
A gente vai trabalhar como Time.
Então a ideia é a gente ver tudo isso. Ele está fazendo baking do processo como um todo, puxar as imagens. Enfim.
E make deploy que ele pediu aqui. Make deploy.
Então vamos fazer um inicio. Deploy.
Beleza. Então, o que ele está fazendo ali? Ele está baixando as imagens, né?
E aqui embaixo, ele está basicamente criando um ambiente, o Sftp, o postgress e o ambiente como um todo.
E dizendo ali que está tudo. Healthy tá.
O que aconteceu enquanto vocês testam aí? O que aconteceu? Vamos abrir o arquivo Make, para ver o que o Arquivo Make Tem Tá.
Então o arquivo Make nada mais é do que ele. Um shell maravilhoso.
Onde ele traz algumas informações.
E aqui o que? Que a gente vai começar a ver, né?
Ele deu Emit.
Deploy. Então aqui, ó, quando eu dou um in it.
O que ele faz. Ele cria.
As dependências. Então ele vai criar um ambiente. Vem, vi.
Tá aqui pra gente. Ele vai instalar.
Os pips. Ah, ele vai fazer um Docker compose Build Sftp.
Ele vai dar um eco falando que o ambiente está.
Cara. Eu amo Make, velho. Acho que todo mundo aqui usa quem não usa.
Adote Make. Para a sua vida. A coisa mais linda que existe, né?
Aí. Você tem aqui o deploy que ele vai fazer? Ele vai fazer um doc com pose up.
Então, se eu vir aqui no Docker com pose.
Eu tenho aqui os serviços que eu tenho. Então, North Wind Pay Legacy.
Eu tenho Sftp. Eu tenho Postcress.
Buzzicamente.
As permissões e os né.
Os Ms e o volume para que a gente possa acessar esses caras.
Então ele fez um deploy aqui.
Vamos ver aqui no make de novo.
Make Deploy. Aí ele vai executar um Legacy Runner. Bootstrap, Runtime.
Para subir o Bootstrapping.
Depois ele vai dar um peixe no diretor. Um acesso do make no Migrate.
E depois ele vai executar o Runtime Stars para verificar se está tudo certo.
Então, basicamente, é isso que a gente deu início para inicializar.
E um deploy para literalmente botar o ambiente up.
Tá.
Pergunta.
E aí? Sucesso não.
Sim. Não deu.
Subiu.
Sim.
Rua. Vai indo aí. Deixa, eu vou esperar um minutinho para todo mundo conseguir.
Fazer.
Beleza. Uma das coisas aqui enquanto a gente fala, né?
A gente pode também.
Se falhar, a gente está utilizando aqui muito mais a parte humana. E obviamente, você vai ver de uma L M Para Fazer Isso Né.
Por exemplo, assim.
Você pode vir aqui.
A gente pode abrir aqui uma nova.
Um novo grok. Eu vou chamar ele de End to End que a gente vai trabalhar hoje.
E aí eu posso falar o seguinte.
Is it making each and make deploy.
E basicamente, o que a Lm vai fazer, executar basicamente os passos que a gente vai fazer.
Entretanto, né.
A grande questão.
é.
é que ele vai pensar.
Como, de fato, fazer isso.
Então, quando a gente olha o que. Qual o trabalho da Llm.
é literalmente pensar: essa é a grande característica dele.
Por isso que, quando a gente começou a utilizar llms chat ipt lá, dois anos, dois anos e meio atrás.
Elas eram efetivas. Elas eram boas, mas, cara, elas funcionavam muito mais como boilerplate. Como.
Acelerador de código para te responder certas coisas hoje. Por que ela é inteligente? Pela capacidade de reasoning dela.
Então, quando eu dou um making deploy, o que o Reasoning vai fazer.
Cara. Ele vai pensar qual o ambiente. Ele vai ver o que ele tem que chamar.
Ele vai verificar se o Docker está funcionando ou não. Está.
E daí? Ele tem acesso ao ambiente. Ele já vai executar o Docker para você.
Então ele vai literalmente tentar fazer isso funcionar de fim, a fim.
Então, nesse caso, aqui, quando eu peço para ele fazer um make.
Ele já sabe que ele vai entrar ali dentro do Make File.
Ele vai entender todos os processos. Ele vai verificar se ele consegue inicializar.
Então aqui ele conseguia inicializar, por exemplo, a mesma coisa.
Então ele deu um make in each make deploy.
E aqui, por exemplo, está o Brief Spec funcionando para vocês terem ideia. Então, quando eu pedi para ele.
Como é um evento de inicialização? Ele captou o tipo evento.
Então ele deu qual impacto ele deu? Qual Current State.
Ele deu probe. Ele deu. Quais foram as ações que foram executadas.
Recover follow up. Se existe. E o Outcome Brief.
Status, Dony, eu só preciso ler isso.
Status. Donny outcome local. North wind Pay Runtime Centralized and Healthy.
A human action known.
Com a prova de que isso funcionou.
Making Each Local Development Environments Make Deploy.
Pôs os esquema, Doc. Compose Ps. Docker Post Fuas N Sftp.
Tá beleza.
A grande questão é, a gente está entendendo? Enquanto a gente vai.
Pô, deu problema, não deu.
O que que aconteceu então a gente vai navegando passo a passo. Então, o que a gente fez, né?
Nós fomos aqui no dia um lá do repositório Run. Dia um.
Viemos aqui no Boot.
Depois do boot que a gente fez, né? A gente basicamente fez o cone do repositório e a gente tentou Dar Um Make Nietzsche E Um Make Deploy.
Com Llm ou no terminal. Tanto faz. Você tem que estar no contexto do projeto.
Nesse caso, eu utilizei o super engineering. Então eu fiz o, né?
Eu adicionei esse projeto dentro do Super Engineering.
Abrir uma nova llm.
Inicialmente, eu abri uma nova. Um novo terminal, né?
Quando eu abri o novo terminal, ele já pegou com o texto do meu projeto. Então, se eu dou um Pwd.
Ele está aqui dentro do projeto.
E aí eu vou dar um make in niche, né?
Um comando. Porque o make existe aqui.
Então ele vai olhar para esse arquivo. Pô, ele já existe um making. Ele vai tentar inicializar.
Esse cara aqui. Pô beleza. Make, niche.
Funcionou. Sim, make deploy tá.
Ou eu posso tentar chamar uma Llm. Qual que seja ela. Se eu estiver tendo problema.
Eu vou falar. Cara executa para em mil making it make deploy. Vamos supor que ele vai dar algum problema.
Você vai ler o problema, entender qual o problema, ou ele vai teoricamente lupar e tentar resolver.
Então teve gente aqui que teve problema, por exemplo?
Em Windows. E daí, cara? O que está acontecendo? Cláudio, qual o problema? Pô? Não tenha permissão tal por causa disso. Disso. Beleza.
Faz um fix para mim. Ela vai corrigir.
Esse cara. A ideia é você entender o que está acontecendo por debaixo dos panos.
Não dá para você ser um bom ai. Native Engineer.
Se você não entender cada pedaço que você está fazendo.
Obviamente, quando o codebase fica extremamente gigante, você vai conseguir saber tudo que está sendo feito pelos agentes. Não, não consegue.
Então você tem que pensar uma forma de como você vai estar atualizado dentro dessa fábrica.
Eu vou ensinar para vocês lá na sexta feira. Como que eu faço. Tá.
Como é o meu processo? Porque eu tenho uma fábrica rodando vinte e quatro por sete, por exemplo.
A Curv está aqui executando. Tem várias coisas executando.
Chega. A tarefa passa pelo requisito. Decompõe, escreve, faz e blá, blá, blá.
E durante a semana tenho treze, catorze, quinze testes que, se forem executados, que foram validadas, Cisdic passou, e assim por diante.
Como que eu vejo.
E como eu sei. E eu estou no topo de tudo isso.
Então, no início, você vai gastar muito token mental para entender o processo como um todo.
E eventualmente você vai começar a ir passeando.
E trabalhando por aí.
Vamos ver aqui o que a gente teve. Deu pau no Windows. Eu fugi do Windows. Tá rodando uma. Venha um buntu.
Extinguindo todo dia no meu trabalho. Bom, é uma boa forma de você desestressar.
Aqui. Tudo certo. Tudo certo. Composta de pé. Poxa os Sft Purpose, Healthy Runtime Stories confirma.
Mostra se de abrir a pergunta no Llm do Surpreendido. Assim, vamos aprender também.
Eu já fiz aqui, ó.
Veio aqui. Escolhe a Lime que você quer que você tem configurado.
E aqui. Você.
Executa o. Execute Making It.
You make the boy, que é exatamente o que está aqui dentro.
Desse carinha aqui do cinco making it make deploy.
Basicamente, eu estou pedindo para ele executar.
Então vamos executar esse cara aqui. Execute making it and make deploy. Eu já fiz aqui, ó.
Executou tanto na Llm. Passou na llm.
Como making it make deploy. Aqui sou eu. Executando o mano, digitando que nem um macaco.
Coisa que a gente não faz mais, né?
Era muito menos dá pra Lm: e ficar lá assistindo, esperando. Pra que eu vou digitar aqui, ficar.
Olhando. Não, isso é muito. Dois mil e vinte e cinco. A gente não faz mais isso, né? Mas para vocês verem.
E entendendo como que esse call funciona esse processo. Beleza.
O André mandou. O quê? Pô, tá tudo up.
They see.
Loop, beleza.
é token, tal. A gente gasta bastante também.
E aí todo mundo conseguindo.
Fomos.
Não é boa.
Beleza, tá? A gente vai devagarzinho. Vou fazendo paradas.
Fica tranquilo pra gente. Quero que todo mundo consiga.
Porque, acredite, quando chegar no segundo, terceiro dia, vai dar um momento muito foda da gente estar desenvolvendo e construindo juntos. Então.
Eu quero que vocês passem passo a passo comigo, tá.
Debugando, fixando. é isso, gente. é tempo. Cadeira não tem como tá.
Aqui. Eu vou te mostrar. Eu vou reduzir para vocês o caminho e vou dar literalmente o caminhão das pedras Para Vocês Utilizarem Isso De Uma Forma.
Efetiva em Enterprise Scale. Mas no final do dia, você vai ter que.
Fazer aí, ó beleza? O Carlos também conheceu.
O César conseguiu também. Beleza. Show.
Então, cinco, cinco. Face, tá. O cinco foi.
A gente tem que ter confirmado que os sistemas estão up com o pouser. Está up.
Agora a gente vai executar o seis Rhythm do seis. Então vamos ver o que a gente tem no seis. Aqui.
Então, olha só. Que legal. O que ele está falando aqui a gente vai começar a tentar entender um pouco.
O ambiente como um todo, né?
Então a gente vai copiar. Vai lá no seis. Vai copiar esse texto aqui. ó.
E a gente vai fazer.
Uma pergunta para llm.
Então eu estou aqui. Eu vou abrir uma Lm.
Você pode escolher o que você quer.
Nesse caso, eu vou usar o Groc, tá.
é.
Não, eu não fui direto. Não, Alan, a gente passou pelo um, dois, três e quatro. Agora que a gente está no cinco.
No final do dia, cara, se você já tem o llm.
é feito disponível de um ao quatro.
é para você setar um ambiente. Basicamente, o seu ambiente pode ser verse Code.
Pode ser Simux. Pode ser o que você quiser, contando que você tenha llm já configurado para você executar.
Literalmente que começa a funcionar mesmo. é o cinco.
Que é o Boot para a gente inicializar e fazer o deployment do ambiente falar pô beleza. Tô aqui com O Ambiente Tá Funcionando.
Tenho ele no Docker. O Docker Tarant.
O ambiente negado.
Agora a gente vai começar a fazer o quê?
Trabalho de Blank Slate. A gente vai começar do zero, né?
Então o que é do zero? O que eu estou falando para ele.
Telefone seguinte. Leio ridme.
Responde pra mim. O que é North Windpay em duas sentências.
Quais são os quatro comandos.
Na Surface de operação.
O que? Que é, frozen? A gente vai entender isso agora. O que significa Matched Means?
E por que o Modern.
Ele não existe. Ainda existe. Ainda.
Então a gente vai fazer algumas perguntas aqui. Basicamente, a gente está começando a exploração.
Então qualquer projeto Brown Field que você quer fazer.
Não só perguntar pro readm Md. Porque o Reed e o Md pode não estar atualizado.
Mas obviamente, o que você quer fazer é fazer uma pesquisa no rhidming e no repositório para entender o que é esse repositório.
E daí, na minha opinião.
Eu instalaria o Brief Spec.
Se vocês quiserem. Então vou deixar disponível aqui para vocês. O link.
O Brief Spec é essa interface humana de leitura.
Então ele vai condensar essa leitura. Que ele vai cuspir de várias formas. Num processo bonito para você ler.
Então, olha só. Que legal. O que ele vai cuspir para mim aqui. Ele vai cuspir uma leitura muito gostosa, tá.
Então aqui, ó beleza. Vou responder aqui. O que que é então, o que é o Northw Windp em duas Sentenças Tá Overnight Card Settlement For Machantes Então Trabalha Né Esse Cara.
De noivo, né?
No repositório.
Ele está em Run. Então aqui, ó.
Ou Anderson. Ele está em Run.
Todos os scripts que a gente está executando. Estão aqui todas as etapas.
Todas elas. E vai ser durante a semana inteira. Assim tá? Todas elas vão aparecer aqui.
Então abriu D um, que é o dia um vai ter todas aqui, dia dois e assim, consecutivamente. Tá.
Consequentemente.
Consecutivamente. Acho que é isso.
Prompt seis. Então vamos entender aqui.
Legal. Overnight.
A gente está trabalhando com uma planta já legada.
Messy Custom Drop.
Cinco dias, a gente vai construir esse sistema como um todo. O repositório que usa um botequim de engenharia genética.
Um Frozen Sftp com Java vinte e um com postgress. A linha para fazer o settlement.
Cinco tipos de arquivo.
E o embalde Drop para receber essa informação.
Beleza. Quais são os comandos que a gente utiliza? Making it para inicializar, para fazer o Venv, o ambiente.
Virtual. Construir o container make deploy.
Para fazer o Sftp, o posturas e as migrações, para verificar se está tudo saudável.
O make status, né?
Quatro rolls, mais posters para verificar se tá tudo certo. Se está operacional.
You make run para a gente testar o ambiente, né?
E aí, o que ele fala aqui? Nesse caso.
O que é um Frozen.
E aí a gente vai aprendendo esses conceitos.
De engenharia de software, de engenharia de dados.
De coisas mais genéricas de infraestrutura. O que é.
Então, por exemplo, se a gente olhar a pasta Legacy.
A pasta Contracts a pasta Gen.
E a pasta infra. O Rid me diz para não editar esses caras, porque basicamente, eles são a estrutura atual Que A Gente Tem.
Principalmente o contrato. O contrato é congelado. Por quê? Porque ele já foi assinalado. A gente vai entender um pouquinho. O Que é Isso.
Assim como gerador de dados e a par de infraestrutura. Então ele já está funcionando. Então, o que é um Frozen.
São partes do seu repositório.
Que são congeladas e que, teoricamente, você não quer mexer. E aí vem um ponto importante. Aqui.
Isso é uma parte do quê? Do Harness.
Então manda parte dos Harness que você cria para os agentes. é falar, cara.
Do not Edit, você não edita tal tal tal. Você não faz tal tal.
You saw? A parte do Hardness. Onde você está passando? Os dontes.
Para o sistema. O que pode acontecer, por exemplo, se um agente alucinar ou se qualquer tipo de requisito que parece dúbio, enfim.
Ele pode. Não tem nada que literalmente fale para ele, para ele não acessar ou fazer alguma coisa. Obviamente que Os Modelos São Muito Inteligentes Hoje Mas Ele Pode Fazer.
E pode passar despercebido.
Do Poor Requests pode passar despercebido pelo seu review do seu agente e pode passar despercebido por você, mas o Cara Pode Ter Feito.
Uma mudança no teste. Ele pode ter feito ali um hardcode dentro do contrato.
Então, o que você quer fazer quando você inicializa um repositório como um todo, entender quais são os seus flows.
E literalmente adicionar isso na memória.
Adicionar isso como literalmente, um mandato.
Para o seu agente.
Tá.
Beleza. O que? Match Means, né.
A planta toda vez que a gente fala da planta aqui.
é literalmente o ambiente, né? Um ambiente como um todo que pega o dado. Raw passa pelo Java, faz o processo.
Cospe do outro lado e assim por diante.
Então a gente vai ter uma evidência.
Para garantir.
Que o valor que a gente está esperando está correto.
Então a gente vai comparar basicamente o valor quando a gente rodar o ambiente.
A gente vai ter um valor que a gente vai chamar de reconciliação.
A gente vai validar se. Essa evidência bate com o que foi? Com o que aconteceu.
E o ambiente modern. O ambiente modern é o que a gente na quarta feira.
Vestindo os hats de engenheiro e analíticos e engenheiro. A gente vai fazer amanhã. A gente vai só trabalhar com A Tradução Do Java E Com As Melhores Práticas De Engenharia De Software.
E na quarta, a gente vai literalmente fazer.
A criação do ambiente moderno. Então a gente vai ver um pouquinho mais que o ambiente moderno. Vai ser o Que A Gente Vai Usar Por Exemplo.
Para esse ambiente, tá.
Então, beleza são fatos. E olha só. Que legal. O que o Brief Spec faz, né?
Ele te traz? Por exemplo, quais foram as fontes de pesquisa que ele fez? Em quais linhas ele fez? Então Ele Tem Ali Um Retrieval.
Interessante. E aí, no final, ele vem como Outcome Brief.
Então ele te fala, cara? Done Outcome Five Questions answered.
Human Action? Não. Qual é a prova?
Se tem algum Gap, se tem alguma coisa próxima, se tem alguma coisa aberta.
Tá vendo que do jeito que você lê, é muito mais gostoso e estruturado. Isso é o Brief Spec.
Luan. Como que eu instalo Brief Spec.
Pega o link do Brief Spec.
Bota no chat.
Instala o Free Brief Spec para mim, é só isso.
Então a ideia é vocês conseguirem utilizar quem quiser, né?
Então pega aqui. Install.
E aí?
O comando.
E, por exemplo, eu estalo global. Então você pode ter tanto o ambiente global quanto você pode ter. O que acontece.
Do projeto.
Então eu venho aqui. Brief Spec.
Copio.
I, por exemplo, se eu estou usando, aí é que vai, né? Por exemplo, eu estou usando grock, né? Então Se Eu Der Um Install Eu Vou Instalar No Groc Beleza.
Se eu vier aqui e abrir no Kimi e eu der um install, ele vai instalar no Kimi lá pra mim.
Se eu vier aqui no Cloud Code, ele vai instalar no Cloud Code pra mim.
E o Brief Spec é disponível basicamente em todos esses.
E que ele tem disponível hoje. Que funciona. Out of the box.
Out of the box cloudy.
Claud code. Não, desculpa. Codecs cloud codecode ou wipi groc Kimi.
Copilot experiments. Eu nunca testei. Literalmente cursou experimental.
E Gus experimentam, tá.
Mas nesses caras aqui, eles funcionam.
Se funciona no My Party, vai funcionar basicamente para tudo. Na verdade.
O Diogo perguntou: essas expressões dos ridícul não são determinísticas. Exatamente. Não são. São só regras.
Que Llm pode ou não pode seguir.
E aí, o que você pode fazer? Obrigar elas, de várias formas. Uma boa ideia é um pré Commit um post, talvez.
Uma outra é você mudar o C H Mod.
Que também assim eu já vi ali fazer umas coisas legais. Ela mudar e personificar, fazer e depois falar. Pô Beleza Não Fiz Mas Ela Fez Na Verdade.
Existe.
Garantia. Vou ser bem sincero para você. No que eu vejo no meu cenário.
Não existe garantia.
Mas o que o Diego.
O Diogo falou serve como dica para a gente. O seguinte.
Duas coisas.
O mínimo possível. Você vai dar o mínimo possível.
E você vai fazer o trustboard Verify, você vai confiar validando.
Então, o que é confiar validando cara? A gente vai adicionar o máximo de Guardrails para ter segurança. Mas mesmo Assim Não é Uma Segurança.
Se você fala pra mim, pô, botei ch mod.
é? Pô. Tirei visibilidade. Nunca vai fazer isso, cara. Pode personificar para o consumo usuário que ela tem na sua Máquina E Ela Pode Fazer Então Assim.
Se você falar que não vai fazer. Se alguém te falar que uma instrução vai garantir que você não faça isso. Mentira.
Mas dá para fazer algumas coisas. Como Evol, por exemplo, dá pra gente adicionar alguns guardrails na hora da onde? Do Supurry Quest.
Na hora de uma mudança de arquivo.
O foda é você ter isso muito bem documentado. Então, assim.
Talvez. é uma lente.
A gente não viu que o Diogo tá vendo? Pô beleza aqui são instruções.
O que eu gosto de fazer. Diogo.
Para não ficar muito Crazy sobre isso.
Eu gosto de ter isso lá no Cloud que a gente vai colocar ou no Agents Md.
Mas eu gosto de fazer uma outra coisa. Eu gosto de ter um agente.
Que sempre é o cara de Security Review.
Então, no final, cara de alguns rounds, você passa um cara de Security Review para verificar se.
Mas de novo, não existe segurança. Dá para a gente adicionar algumas coisas, mas difícil falar, pô, tem como.
Aniquilar isso. Na minha experiência, não.
Com os modelos. São muito bons hoje em respeitar muita coisa, mas tem modelo que não respeita.
é bom. é bom. é bom olhar. Isso bastante. Tá.
O Marcelo perguntou.
Que ele não entendeu. Então.
No Superengineering Marcel.
Você tem vários Hardness que você conecta.
Então uma coisa isso confunde no começo também. Tá.
Uma coisa, por exemplo, é eu pegar o Woman Pie.
E conectar ele com o Grok. Eu posso fazer isso. Posso, porque Woman Pie é um multi harness.
Who my pai, conecta com Open, router e o Open router possibilita você acessar quinhentos e setenta modelos diferentes.
Outra coisa é eu me conectar com o Hardness do Grok.
Que aí eu já acesso ele.
Do Hardness dele. Então quando eu venho aqui no meu. Eu tenho o quê? Eu tenho codecs. Eu tenho cloud. Eu Tenho Grok Eu, Tenho Kimi E Eu Tenho All Mypie.
Então são diferentes, Harness, que eu tenho aqui.
Então no meu. Aqui eu estou acessando direto o Groc direto.
Tá, então.
Ele está indo direto aqui. Beleza.
E aí, enquanto eu estava conversando, todo mundo conseguiu botar um ambiente para rodar.
Me fala. Aí deu tudo certo.
Deu? Bom, não deu? Bom, o que aconteceu.
Me. Fala aí, galera do Windows! Conseguiu! Quem conseguiu.
Ah, boa pergunta, Davi.
Luan. Se você já tem Open router com todos esses modelos, porque mesmo assim você configura as llms.
Porque, por exemplo, no Open router.
Você vem aqui e é legal pra vocês tirarem essas dúvidas. Tá no Open router. Você vem aqui.
E você compra créditos. Então eu venho no Open router aqui, e eu venho. Cara, eu quero adicionar cem.
Beleza. Quando adicionam esses cem dólares.
Eu vou literalmente usar esses cem.
Nos llms que eu pedi. Se eu vier aqui no Groc Subscription, por exemplo.
Eu vou nos planos do Grok.
Eu venho aqui e pago o Super Grok Heavy, por exemplo, que é trezentos, que é o meu plano atual.
Mas aí eu uso ele até.
Estralar o mundo.
E assim, uma das coisas que eu acho que todo mundo já sabe, é.
Pagar trezentos do Super Grok Heavy.
E botar três cem no Open. Router são coisas completamente diferentes. Por exemplo, aqui.
Se a gente fosse botar em valores.
Possivelmente o equivalente de não ter uma assinatura dessa. Estaria pagando cinco, seis, sete mil dólares facilmente.
Cara. O Super Grok.
Eu já estou. Eu estouro tres de vinte x todo dia no cloud.
E eu estouro toda semana a minha de codecs.
Eu não consegui estourar ainda do que me vivas, que é a maior. Mas eu já. Eu já fiz a Alegreta Eu Já Estourei Alegreto.
Eu nunca consegui estourar super Grock Heavy. Nunca, nunca consegui.
E eu vou te falar.
Eu estou usando ela assim eu não uso mais cloud. Por exemplo, faz umas duas semanas que eu não toco No Cloud Mais Eu Estou Usando Codecs.
E Groc. Então, assim eles têm um limite gigantesco.
E a questão do Super Grock Heavy, para mim, não é nem a assinatura por causa do Grock Bot.
Então o Grok Bot, quando você tem o Super Grok Heavy ou o plano.
O plano premium do cursor.
Você ganha o Grok Bot.
E é por isso que, na verdade, eu tenho assinatura. Mas, cara, ele como modelo, assim, tem me surpreendido.
Sinistramente muito bom. Não tenho o que falar. Muito pelo contrário. Só coisas boas.
Então é para isso. Entendeu, Davi? Uma coisa é eu comprar que creches a vários modelos. Outra coisa é eu Chegar Lá Na Opna E Falar Cara.
Pagar dois cem da assinatura da subscription da Openai. Deixa eu pagar dois, cem da cloud Code.
Vit X, por exemplo, entendeu.
Então você tem esse tipo de coisa que vai facilitar você.
Então, se eu fosse pô, estou começando agora. Quero experimentar vários modelos e tal Open router.
Para brincar um pouquinho. Mas eu obviamente eu vou.
Vou direcionar você a escolher um modelo.
Um Harness ali. Ou Codex ou Cloud Code, ou assim por diante.
Eu se fosse recomendar o seu primeiro. Ah, Luan, você escolhe entre quê.
Eu sempre fui um fã muito grande de Cláudio. Porque até.
Sei lá. Seis meses atrás. Cinco meses atrás.
Não tinha nada que conseguisse chegar perto do cloud em geral, como um todo. Integração, customização.
Inteligência em geral. Para mim, ele ganhava.
Em geral, muitos dos outros.
Nos últimos três, quatro meses. Cara.
Ele está atrás dos outros. Na minha opinião.
Então, por exemplo, eu começaria com certeza no codec. O Codecs para mim, de todos de assinatura.
Eu pagaria com certeza bastante. Tá.
é.
O Brief Spec é acionado automaticamente. Sim, você vai instalar ele na sessão. Você vai ter que abrir uma outra sessão.
Porque ele é um plugin. Então ele é adicionado no via Post Huck.
E ele vai funcionar para você nos próximos. Mas você não precisa fazer nada. Ele automaticamente vai identificar e vai Começar A Fazer Isso Para Você.
O Lucas Ali sugeriu o Kimi ou de psique. Gosto muito também absurdamente.
Acho que maravilhoso. Como modelo.
Acho de psique também. Muito bom. Como Api tem agora o Deep Hardness, né? Que é.
Muita gente falando.
Eh.
She gostou bastante. Gosto bastante de como ele trabalha. Toda a parte de plugins.
Mas eu não usei ele ainda na prática, tá? Quero ver um pouquinho quando a gente tiver.
Ele mais bem disponível em algumas interfaces, para ver como ele vai se comportar.
Só um minutinho.
Beleza. Agora vamos voltar aqui para.
Fizemos o regime, fizemos o seis, né? De fazer a leitura e entender.
Uma ideia. Agora a gente vai para o set.
Que que a gente quer fazer é o set. A gente quer dar um run make Stars do not change any file.
A gente não precisa fazer isso, porque ele não vai mudar. A gente está sendo explícito aqui.
Mas basicamente, eu posso pedir para ele fazer um Rammex Starons.
Ou a gente pode fazer. Então vou chegar aqui no mesmo chat que eu tenho. Run status.
Ou eu posso abrir o terminal, né.
E aí eu vou rodar o make.
O Make Staras. Vai verificar se está tudo ok aqui nos Dockers, né? Lá está tudo bonitinho, tá? Healthy.
Os Dockers estão criados, Opens, e assim por diante.
Beleza.
Tão bem simples. O prompt set.
O Prompt a oito. Agora que vai começar a ficar interessante.
Que agora a gente vai executar uma parada muito legal, que é o seguinte.
A gente vai rodar um teste, tá? Então a gente vai rodar um Make run e o tipo.
Do cenário que a gente vai fazer. Tá.
Então eu vou executar isso via Llm para vocês verem.
Então eu executei aqui Roma status.
Aqui. Quem pegou foi o Beriff Speck.
Então mixt as exit zero The runtime is healthy.
Então, tudo bem aqui.
Prob.
Usuário, Mix, status. Nenhum impacto.
Que a gente. Healthy, está tudo certo com ele. Outcome, Brief, Donny.
Beleza post cruéis de dezesseis quatorze. Todos Sftp Rolls. Como é que estão funcionando?
Agora a gente vai falar o seguinte, Run, que aí vai ser o nosso Prompt oito.
Run Make Run Type, Zero One, Scenario, Valued, Minimal.
O que a gente vai fazer. A gente vai rodar o mínimo.
Cenário viável fim a fim.
Para verificar se.
O que vai ser gerado. Ou seja, a gente está meio que fazendo um mímica do ambiente.
Quando ele executa.
Para verificar se a evidência gerada.
Ela está correta no sistema.
Então, olha só. Vamos ver o que aconteceu.
Ou como que o Brief Spec vai me retornar. Isso tá.
Então o Brief Spec me falou: cara, tipo um válido.
Completado. O Bet bateu.
Cento e três, quarenta e cinco.
Rodamos esse cara aqui. Temos esse, né.
Esse Jason. A gente tem o arquivo de reconciliação.
Ele já quebrou o arquivo para mim. Aqui. Status matchets.
Source veio cento e setenta e três.
Quando aplicou o Net Amount, veio cento e setenta e três, quarenta e cinco.
O Delta Zero zero, fonte aplicada não foi rejeitada.
He Had Currency e Brl.
Beleza. Então a gente rodou essa evidência?
Mas beleza. O que significa essa evidência? Vamos tentar entender o que significa essa evidência.
Vamos lá. Na pasta de evidência para tentar entender.
O que é de fato.
Então, vamos lá.
Pasta de evidência deve ter aparecido para vocês. Se vocês escreveram aqui.
Deixa eu ver. Ela foi comentada. Mas aqui ela está como.
Hidden, né? Então eu vou tirar ela do Git. Ignore.
Então eu vou. Provavelmente ela estava aqui.
Ah, tá bom.
Aqui. ó, ele só fez mesmo. Então a evidência.
E aí tem um arquivo chamado Evidence. Cadê você?
Reconciliei se o Godd Jason tá aqui.
Aquele arquivo que a gente acabou de ler?
Ele está aqui escrito. Realmente.
Yeah, uma das formas de você começar a entender um pouquinho sobre o processo, né?
Legal. O Mário teve um resultado diferente.
Porque ele teve uma conexão de erro com Sftp.
Theyi, Mário. Como que você, Márcio? Como que você vai conseguir corrigir isso? Aí tá.
Fora. Todo mundo conseguiu executar esse cara aqui.
O que que aconteceu? Veja qual o problema.
Tenta identificar.
Viu como que é legal. Cada um tem um problema diferente.
Beleza. O que que ele fez basicamente aqui teve erro de Sftp. Quando é que você está resolvendo aqui, Cláudio, controlo. E resolveu.
Billy is acquire. Eu não quero saber o que que ele está corrigindo. Eu quero saber por que ele deu esse erro.
Beijo. Guilherme conseguiu! A malte bateu do mesmo jeito.
Claudinho já achou. Eu quero saber.
O que aconteceu? Essa é a questão da gente ser Nietzsche. Sobre o processo. A gente precisa entender.
Encontrei causa raiz do oro como Smete. Não o cenário de lá e do contrato.
é um bug de permissão de ambiente. Beleza. Boa.
Os aliens. Está dando cinquenta voltas e escrevendo uma Bíblia. Boa.
Já posta. O motivo, Match.
Vamos lá, pessoal. Temos cento e quarenta pessoas. Interajem.
Isso é para vocês. Vocês vão aprender se vocês forem.
Ao longo do tempo. Vocês vão aprender muito, tá? Então vamos. Todo mundo juntos, tá.
A ideia desse Boot Camp é você estarem no comando, a gente executar, passar por isso, conversar.
Trocar lá ele mil vezes e assim por diante. Tá.
Started Brief bang everybody. Se é um Hulk ou não.
O acesso ao Sandbox estava bloqueada.
Resumindo, fixed.
Windows. Compatibility issues Windows com Docker. é dose. Pois é. Estou no making it, beleza, mas tá indo.
Java Reject. The Batch With Sftp. Beleza. Aprove. Sftp não conseguiu produzir.
Então, exatamente isso que eu queria.
O que é evidência. A evidência é garantir que o sistema está up and running.
Com as permissões corretas e consegue executar o passo a passo.
Definitivamente muita gente não consegue, porque Windows tem um nível de permissionamento.
Diferente. Então pode dar bug de permissionamento.
Então a gente quer identificar qual é o problema? E aí, como vai funcionar na prática?
Na prática, a ideia é você. Como engenheiro, agente. Pô, eu vou lançar um bug report. Eu vou chamar uma Iss no repositório.
Para poder corrigir esse cara para Windows. Tá.
Então a gente vai começar a trabalhar exatamente dessa forma.
Eu também sou do Make Niche. Não tem problema. Vamos seguindo. Olha só.
Causa exata. J a non hostky exception reject host key.
Tá.
Vamos ver aqui.
Some users reported this issue both can just explain in details. What it is.
Pô. Eu sei tudo. Obviamente não, mas Ellie sabe.
Então a grande ideia da gente ser curioso é exatamente isso. Márcio falou que houve.
Um problema reportado aqui, beleza. O que que é? Vamos descobrir.
O que significa esse cara.
Engraçado.
Beleza. Andressa conseguiu! Top.
Caraca. Nimotron Tres Ultrafree executou. Sem problema.
Ainda mais é que tocar ainda no Making It Orca Cloud, aqui. Boa, vai lá. Vai dar certo.
Como igreja.
De credencial. E não é.
Isso não surge. Aconteceria melhor para uma nova sessão.
Hmm hmm.
This plant is built to fail that way on purpose.
Olha só. Que interessante, tá.
Essa plantinha que eu deixei aqui para vocês.
Before. Any sftp.
Antes de você rodar qualquer comando. Sftp.
O que acontece, tá.
Ele vai verificar o que o Ssh.
E o que ele faz? Ele verifica se esse cara tem um Ssh.
Presente. Rsa. Enfim.
O processador. Puxa esse cara pelo ponto Xml.
E se o nome estiver faltando? Se ele não achar, ele rejeita.
Toma.
Vocês foram curiosos. é isso.
Essa é a grande parada do negócio. Olha, o João já teve Outcome Brief. Que massa, hein? João.
Status Blockett na sua face.
Curtir, curtir. Olha que legal!
Cara. Eu amo isso que eu criei. Sério.
Sou um ser humano tão mais feliz que vocês. Não têm noção.
Mas enfim. Make status, fail human if you're ready ran pseudo user modes are fresh terminal. Yeah, blah, blah, blah.
Top.
Ah, porque esse erro só aconteceu no Windows. Na verdade, não. Não só acontece no Windows, pode acontecer em outra também. Finally Bitch.
Beach Batch bull containers are healthy.
Posters and sftp perfeito. Isso é algum tipo de preconceito com windows users of course.
Não, na verdade, é cara. Basicamente, o que o Java vai fazer.
Ele vai usar essa classe Jay Craft para poder verificar se você tem um public host.
Então se você não tiver, ou se você não fez você abrir o novo. Um boom, alguma coisa nova? Ele não tem.
Ele vai rejeitar. Por que ele faz isso agora? A gente vai entender. Aqui.
That Happens in Sftp Gateway Connect. Então aqui ele tem um Public Static.
Que vai fazer um tro.
Então ele vai jogar para cima.
E basicamente, ele está declarando esse cara.
Pegando qual não host. Transformando para String.
Sessão. Username. Host, porta.
Setor Password verificou se ele tem esse valor. Sessão. E se não, ele vai jogar um erro.
Então, na verdade, o problema real.
é porque você não tem uma chave teoricamente. Então, strict host kiss checking yes means never prompt never auto edge Never Continue A Non.
Hard Fail. Então, se eu não tiver, se for ou não, ou se eu tiver uma chave que não está Batendo Com O Seu Público.
Ele dá erro.
Beleza. Python does the same thing with paramiko.
Reject policy against the same file java is just decide that names the exception.
Why this plane to regenerate Keys.
Então, olá. Toda vez que eu executo o que ele vai fazer aqui no Entry Point? Sh.
Ele vai dar um sshh aqui, menos a. E vai pegar esse cara e vai executar.
Brief Spec é foda, né? Ele explica tudo. é muito massa.
Olá. A diferença de Change aqui pra Rose Key.
Ah, boa Executor.
Hein? Que você é lindo, né? Velho.
Bom. Beleza.
O jeito é comprar um Mac, né? Bruno compra amanhã um maczão.
Ou você podia também doar, né? Bruno, você tem trezentos e cinquenta mex. Podia doar.
Luan. Qual mesmo o nome do arquivo de Evidence Please.
Boa. Claro. Evidence.
Ele vai ser a Reconciliation da Jason Reconciliation. Esse é o cara.
Mas eu ainda não entendi o que esse arquivo de reconciliação.
Então aqui ele explicou tudo. Deu o Donnie Brief Watch. Come Brief. Falou Donny Outcome the exceptions to ssh host key rejection.
By the java processor.
Are most always a stale or missing runtime known host fnde sftp.
Tá? Então, basicamente você não tem nenhum. Não, Host. Lá ele vai falhar.
Cara. Você. Se você estiver tendo esse problema, rode o make deploy.
Tente novamente. Não, Edite. O Legacy beleza.
Show. Então.
Sofremos aqui um pouquinho. Tivemos alguns erros. Passamos. Gosto muito desse processo. Esse é o processo.
De engenharia. Só que agora, no oito, eu quero entender um pouquinho mais. Então a gente vai dar um catch Nesse Registro Nesse Documento Aqui.
Então eu vou abrir o terminal só para fazer mesmo. Vou dar um catch só para ler esse arquivo, tá? Esse é O Arquivo Que A Gente Abriu Aqui Logo Mais.
Então ele recebeu um Applied Net amount de cento e setenta e cinco.
Boa, Diego!
Your match.
Top é que a gente tem a evidência.
Fonte batendo com o que estava esperado. Show.
Só que agora o que acontece? Eu ainda não entendi.
Então eu quero que você leia, tá?
Então, não do terminal, não do Git. Lê evidência.
Tá? Responda para mim. O que é o status? O que é o Source Amount.
Why this folder might be missing from gitt sidebar.
A gente corrigiu do Not change. Eu ainda vou perguntar o seguinte. Zero.
What.
O que é uma evidência at First Place. Vamos entender o que significa essa evidência. Por que a gente tem Essa Evidência Por Que é Importante Ter Uma Evidência.
Então, hoje a gente tem uma facilidade de ter todas as respostas. A gente só precisa ser curioso.
Então é literalmente a capacidade de você ir navegando. Eu quero que vocês entendam hoje.
Uma coisa que provavelmente muitos de vocês já fazem. E você, que não faz não tem problema. Comece a fazer.
Tem essa curiosidade dos níveis falhou. Por quê? Deixa eu entender. Pergunta.
Navega cava. Por quê? O que vai te consumir mais? Token mental? é esse início.
Só que é o seguinte: se você não entender o projeto e o processo no início.
Cara no meio pro final.
Acredita no que eu estou te falando.
Um bilhão de vezes pior. Um bilhão de vezes pior.
Então é muito melhor você gastar tempo no início, para você acertar a fundação, configurar, entender cada onça e cada pedaço.
Conseguir literalmente digerir assim por diante.
Você vai literalmente conseguir.
Navegar muito rápido. Então vamos gastar tempo nisso, tá.
Qqq.
Colocou. Ah, ele está tendo Brief Spec, né?
Legal. ótimo. João.
E aí, quem está usando o Brief Spec? O que vocês estão achando do retorno.
Por isso é coisa linda.
Boa. Vamos ler aqui. O que quer então? Tá.
Então ele leu a evidência do arquivo. Então, o que é evidência? Evidência é um pacote por execução de um Bet Que Foi Feito.
é a observação do que realmente aconteceu nessa máquina. Para aquela execução, Hash foi gerado manifesto resultado do Java.
Carga, posturas, reconciliação.
Não é somente o código. Então ele vai executar mesmo passo a passo, do ambiente.
Legacy para ele verificar o que aconteceu ao longo do tempo.
Beleza. Então Read me coloca evidência como match ou not match.
Para verificar se esse valor vai bater como pacote. Então, toda vez que eu executo esse cara.
Ele vai literalmente criar na evidência e vai gerar um pacote do Bet que vai ser executado.
Então, qual é o status? Matchet.
O que significa cada um deles. O que é Source Net Amount Applied Net Amount e Amount Delta.
Então sourcing that amount cento e setenta e três, quarenta e cinco Applied Net Amount, cento e setenta e três, Quarenta E Cinco Também.
E o Delta, que a diferença é zero.
Então a fonte declarou cento e setenta e três, quarenta e cinco.
E a planta cento e setenta e três, quarenta e cinco, ou seja.
O sistema.
O Tonypower Application. Quando ele viu, ele falou. Olha o resultado.
Desse valor é sessenta e tres. Quarenta e cinco. é o meu contrato.
Eu rodeio Pipeline.
Tirar do Sftp passar no Java.
Copiar, propor os juízo dos Ice procedures e ver o registro.
Deu cento e sessenta e três, quarenta e cinco. Isso quer dizer.
Match. It.
O Golden bateu com o esperado. Então o ambiente Legacy bateu com o arquivo que a gente recebeu. Perfeito, lindo. é Isso Que A Gente, Quer.
Então a fonte declarou cento e setenta e três.
A planta aplicou cento e sessenta e três, a diferença zero.
Isso também está nos arquivos. Como True Sources true station to applied.
Não foi rejeitado. Curmency Brl tá.
Por que esse cara Gee ignored.
Porque basicamente, ele é executado dentro do seu ambiente. Então ele quer refletir a evidência do seu ambiente. Tá.
Esse arquivo não foi corrigido porque os ambientes bateram.
Mas pode acontecer uma hora em que a reconciliação não vai bater com a evidência.
Então eu tenho um registro que eu recebi. Eu tenho um arquivo que eu recebi. Mas quando eu passar ele Pelo Pipeline O Valor Vai Estar Incorreto.
Então o Outcome Brief Donny não tem nada para a gente fazer.
O status é dono. Outcome. é.
Live Evidence.
Para o Bet. Bateu e tal.
A Human Action. O que eu amo do Brief Spec, é que às vezes eu posso. Só quando é coisa Rápida Eu Posso Vir Aqui Só Por Causa.
Eu vi no Outcamb e eu já leio Outcome. Cara Donny, se tiver algum follow up. Alguma pergunta que eu Tenho Que Fazer Ele Coloca Aqui Eu Já Respondo E Sigo.
Beleza. Respiramos.
Até aqui. Como estamos? Cheque.
Pode seguir no mesmo contexto.
Coloca aqui gente pra mim. Vocês estão dormindo?
Bora. Só eu que tô.
Animado aqui que a gente tá indo passo a passo. Todo mundo Jun.
Boa beleza.
Então passo.
Nove, né? Então a gente fez isso?
Teve a prova. Agora a gente vai.
Para o passo dez.
Não, na verdade, desculpa. Agora deixa. Eu ia continuar aqui, tá? Aqui. A gente só executa até o passo nove.
Então vamos voltar aqui para a apresentação.
Beleza. Então, o que aconteceu? A gente conseguiu validar.
Esse processo como um todo.
A gente conseguiu abrir um pacote, executar local e fazer fim a fim.
Tanto em Windows quanto Linux quanto em Mac. Alguns problemas ao longo do caminho, aprendemos.
Exatamente como em que, basicamente.
O Java. Espera na hora que a gente tenta fechar essa conexão com o Sftp.
Ele tenta fazer isso por uma chave ou por um no host? Se você não tiver configurado.
Ele vai dar erro, mas na verdade não porque o processo não funciona, mas porque você não tem uma chave cadastrada.
O fixo disso. Você.
Cara se roda em Windows. Roda em qualquer lugar. Isso é verd.
Beleza. Então conseguimos fechar o processo.
Temos um Bet que funciona perfeitamente com o esperado, com o contrato.
Beleza. Então tá aqui a evidência.
Do arquivo de reconciliação. Jason, ele está aqui. Ele bateu.
Tá tudo certo. Valor maravilhoso.
Os tres valores bateram. Não temos nenhum Del.
Só que.
A gente começa, né.
A ver o seguinte: pô beleza. O ambiente atual funciona muito bem.
Mas qual é a grande sacada.
E daqui começa o nosso projeto. A gente recebe como time.
Acho que peguei o Nugget, persona de arqueólogo.
Gosta dos comentários, Sebastião, olha só.
Acho que peguei um Nugget. A persona de arqueólogo é cavar e cavar cada vez mais.
Entender as nuances nos mínimos detalhes do projeto, seja ele Green ou Brown. Exatamente.
Então a ideia do botcamp.
Ela foi criada.
Para você conseguir abrir sua mente em relação ao que você tem que ser.
Nos dias, ou seja, ao longo dos seus dias, construindo a solução.
E conseguir ter várias visões diferentes.
E obviamente que sem a Ia, isso te traz uma limitação muito grande com a Ia. Isso abre.
Isso faz, se possível, você ter um grupo de pessoas que trabalha junto com você. Então, antigamente pô.
O Luan consegue, por exemplo. Olha só. Que loucura isso eu não sei se vocês já refletiram sobre isso.
Pô. O Luan consegue ser um arquiteto de solução.
Um Lead de Engineer e o Analytics Engineer.
Cara sem Ia. Não com a Ia.
Então olha só a mudança que a gente tem agora. Para vocês entenderem como é o mercado e para onde ele está em.
A gente está indo para uma ideia de Ai Native Engine. E até mais. Exatamente. Então a gente consegue ser O Que A Gente Quiser.
Só depende de como a gente aborda o problema.
Porque tem pessoas que conseguem pessoas que não porque uma é mais inteligente do que a outra. Não, a inteligência Não Se Mede Dessa Forma.
Mas é a forma como você ataca o problema.
E você só vai ter essa cabeça se você participar comigo aqui, quebrar a cabeça.
Desta. Quebrar, ficar até a noite passar no outro dia chegar, testar, eu garanto, para você, com todas as palavras.
Chegou na sexta feira. Você é outro profissional.
Porque são tantos nuggets? São tantas coisas que a gente vai se expor. Porque o que transforma o profissional.
Não é o que ele estuda.
Não é o que ele faz no dia a dia. Começa pelo ambiente. Eu estou colocando para você. Estou colocando Vocês No Ambiente Brown Field Que Vocês Não Têm Nem Ideia.
Eu estou colocando vocês num problema financeiro complexo. E eu estou ensinando as técnicas de como a gente vai abordar esse problema.
Então vocês vão passar por uma semana de incomodação. Mas isso é muito de incômodo. Mas isso é muito bom.
Porque isso vai trazer uma visão diferente para vocês. Vocês vão sair daqui com um bocado de Skill.
Vendo várias coisas diferentes. Aplicando técnica, tem nos frameworks disponíveis.
Então eu quero que vocês tentem viver isso aqui.
é cansativo pô o problema das costas doze horas do plantador.
é gente é cansativo, né? Chegar lá do outro lado não é fácil.
Só parece, mas é fácil. é difícil.
Mas eu garanto, para vocês. Que cara! Uma imersão dessa.
Vai te trazer muitos nuggets legais, beleza. Então fica comigo. Aqui.
E vamos. Geralmente essa galera que. Que fica até o final, tem muita sorte, né?
Beleza.
Show. Então, o que a gente recebeu da Helena? Dias, né? A Partner integration. Aí, nosso, né?
Então a gente recebeu como time. Então, hoje temos cento e trinta e um pessoas.
Né? No time. Recebemos aí.
Um e mail muito importante chamado de North Windpay settlement.
Tá? Então, basicamente, o email que a gente recebeu aqui é a North Windpay. Roda cinco arquivos.
Pelo Sftp Java.
Csv Sanitizado. Postos. Keb.
A gente precisa de uma segunda.
Implementação Independente.
Que possa ler isso, não, Java. E que ainda consiga ter os mesmos outcomes, os mesmos resultados.
A gente tem que recriar.
Isso numa nova arquitetura.
Onde nós possamos trabalhar. O card settlement.
O instant payment.
Payment slip, Ted e machine fees.
Não é para substituir o Java.
Não é para consertar o que já existe.
é simplesmente para a gente ter uma nova forma moderna.
De trabalhar isso.
Eu não estou te pedindo, né? A gente não está pedindo para vocês mandarem um Parser ou modelo ou Lake House Ou As Permissões A Gente Quer Que Vocês Construam.
O processo como um todo. Então nosso trabalho, como Ai Names of Engineers começa exatamente aqui.
Tinha uma aprovação para a gente bolar, pensar e desenvolver.
Um novo ambiente moderno que vai verificar. E vai melhorar o ambiente como um todo. A gente vai fazer Side by side.
Comparar eles. E no final, a gente vai ter.
O Switch, né? Entre esses caras é o que a gente vai fazer.
Beleza. E aqui que a gente começa a pensar nas lentes do arquiteto de solução e do Ai Engineer.
Então eu vou dar cinco minutinhos para vocês.
Para respirar um pouquinho, e a gente vai agora entrar na parte, literalmente.
De como a gente se comporta e do que a gente vê. Tá.
Dez e trinta e dois, dez e vinte e dois. A gente volta, tá?
Já, já. Eu estou aqui.
Bora, B.
E aí alguém trocou de setup, assim como o caio. Também orca coisas novas.
Acho que também é legal fazer uma experimentação como o caio está tentando aí que sai um pouquinho fora do.
Do dia a dia. Eu acho muito legal. O que vocês estão achando do. Oh, my pie. Quem está testando.
O que vocês estão achando? Do ambiente agênico que estão gostando.
Visem ao feedback, para a galera.
And. O meu pai é muito bom, cara.
Que bom. Então, vamos lá.
Beleza. Aquecemos em Gynes. Tudo certo até aqui.
Todo mundo acordado.
Tá.
Beleza. Então, o que a gente vai entrar agora, né? A gente vai entrar com duas lentes diferentes.
O que a gente viu, né? Até agora.
Até agora, a gente executou um tipo. A gente vai passar por cinco tipos ao longo dessa semana. A gente Vai Traduzir Esses Cinco Tipos.
A gente executou com exatidão esse processo.
Até o momento, a gente não teve nenhum Bet que foi negado.
Esse Bet realmente rodou.
E aí a gente recebeu na verdade, um e mail falando que a aprovação desse projeto foi feita, a gente conseguia utilizar.
Normalmente em grandes projetos. O que acontece.
A gente tem algum arquiteto de solução olhando para esse projeto. Então, cara, normalmente, para um projeto cair.
Ali, né.
No colo de.
Engenheiros de dados, um Lead Engineer, um software Engineer. Que seja. Você tem alguém ali em cima?
Que fez a validação e entendimento desse processo, tá.
E aí, obviamente, qual é a grande ideia do arquiteto de solução? E qual é a grande ideia do Ai Engineer Que Explode Hoje No Mercado.
Vamos dar uma olhada nessas duas separações aqui. Como a gente consegue olhar o problema em prismas diferentes, tá.
O que os Solutions Architect. Qual é a característica? Quando você veste ali o Hatch, o que é um Solutions? Architect está procurando.
Ele quer literalmente prestar atenção. Isso aqui é muito importante, tá.
Eu uso isso como cabeceira. Na verdade, tá.
é primeira coisa, cara. Ele quer.
Definir o problema.
E definir o problema. Deixa eu explicar para vocês.
Definição do problema, muitas das vezes não vem do cliente. Olha só. Que engraçado.
A definição do problema. Ela é descoberta.
Ao longo da coleta do processo, com o arquiteto de solução.
Então, quando um arquiteto de solução é muito bom, ele consegue literalmente definir muito bem o problema com o cliente.
Muitas vezes. O cliente nem sabe qual é o problema.
Ele sabe a dor. Ele não sabe o problema. Teoricamente.
Então ele quer decidir muito bem o problema. Ele quer. Ele quer decidir muito bem o requisito.
E ele quer saber uma coisa, cara. O que que Dan significa.
Então, assim pô como que eu olho com a lente de um arquiteto de soluções desse jeito.
Definir o problema, saber o requisito e saber qual a definição.
De Don. Se você usar isso nas suas reuniões. é isso. é isso que você tem que ter.
Basicamente esses três.
Isso automaticamente gera call design que você vai decidir ao longo do tempo, ou seja.
Dissolução. Não está olhando para a tecnologia. Juro para você, é a única coisa que a gente não olha.
A gente. Completamente agnóstico. é isso. Quando eu uso esse Hatch, né?
Mas porque eu sou muito enviesado. Tecnicamente, eu era muito enviesado. Tecnicamente, não tem como nós somos enviesados. Tecnicamente.
Mas a ideia de um arquiteto de solução é não pensar e não olhar dessa forma.
Ele quer sempre prezar.
A qualidade daquela informação.
Isso é uma coisa chata de fazer.
Porque prezar pela qualidade da informação, muitas das vezes.
Diz fazer várias reuniões com pessoas diferentes para tentar achar o mesmo alto campo.
Para que você consiga criar.
Uma ideia de contrato ou de fonte da verdade, o que significa verdade? Qual é a fonte da verdade? Quais São As Fontes Enfim.
Então a grande ideia é decidir documentar.
E Sign. Esse é o problema de muita gente que trabalha no Brasil. Ele documenta, ele decide. Ele recebe as informações, decide isso.
Ele documenta, mas ele não faz o sign que é fazer. O Sign é ir de volta com o cliente. Isso Cara Muitas Poucas Pessoas Eu Conheço.
Que faz. Coletei um bocado de coisa e entendi um bocado de coisa. Tá beleza? Eu quero ver se isso que eu entendi.
Literally reflete o que o cliente espera. Então, por exemplo, eu.
Quando eu estou nos projetos, na picha.
Isso é obrigatório para mim. Eu sempre falo para todos os. Na verdade, eu falo isso para o time de sales.
O time de seis. às vezes eles não gostam. Nenhum cliente gosta muito, mas isso é uma coisa meio que Eu Faço E A Galera Que Já Trabalha Comigo Sabe.
Eu faço reunião com o cliente. Faço tudo o que tem que fazer no final. Ainda volto com o cliente De Novo Antes Do Processo.
Porque eu quero falar para ele o seguinte. Olha.
Eu entendi isso.
Eu vim com uma série de perguntas para realmente fechar o meu entendimento.
E aí eu converso com o cliente. Aí eu falo cara.
Isso aqui que eu estou.
Que eu estou falando para você. é isso é o correto.
E muitas das vezes possam falar uma coisa, por mais que eu tenha feito, inclusive um estudo com Llm.
Sobra vinte, trinta, ainda que não estava certa.
Então esses vinte, trinta vira assumptions.
E a Sumptions é o que faz um projeto não conseguir ser entregue.
é você? Ah, eu acho que é assim. Ah, eu acho que é assado.
Então uma coisa que você quer fazer como arquiteto de solução é olhar pela lente do seguinte: beleza.
Eu coletei. Defini o problema.
Literalmente entendi. Colei os requisitos e eu preciso definir o que é completo.
E fora isso, eu preciso dar o Sign com o cliente. Eu preciso fazer o sign off com o cliente.
Excelente, de uma oferta de soluções.
Quando você olha como arquiteto um ai Engineer. Luan, você trouxe o Solutions Architect.
E você trouxe a lente de um Ya Engineer.
Porque a gente está construindo soluções com Ia.
Então, eventualmente, um Solutions Architect pode ser um Ai Engineer. Um ai Engineer pode ser um Solutions. Architect.
Ou você pode ter duas pessoas separadas olhando isso porque a gente está criando um processo agêntico.
Então, muitos arquitetos de soluções. O que o arquiteto de solução é um cara que tem um conhecimento. Ele veio.
Não existe. E aí eu estou sendo bem enfático, porque não existe um cara que nasceu Solutions. Architect não existe. Você Não Vai Conhecer Nunca Nos Estados Unidos Fora Do País Nunca.
No Brasil. Eu já vi umas coisas assim.
Ah, o cara é Solutions Architect, com vinte e três anos de idade. Mas enfim, não vou entrar nessa seara. Aí tá.
Lá fora do país. Você tem que ter, no mínimo dez, quinze anos de experiência para começar a ser cogitado Como Arquiteto De Solução Porque é O Maior Nível.
Técnico que existe no mercado.
Americano. Então, o que acontece.
Como afeta de solução.
Você foi muito bom numa área. Você virou um líder.
Você trabalhou muito tempo nesses intercâmbios. Então você tem um viés ali que pode ser de infraestrutura, um viés de Engenharia De Software Um Viés De Engenharia De Dados Enfim.
E você vai para Solutions. Architect.
Quando você vira Solutions, Architect.
Você começa a ter que ter uma visão trezentos e sessenta de muita coisa.
Então, por exemplo, eu sempre fui muito preguiçoso para a infraestrutura.
Encostei muito de infraestrutura, mas. Bom, o arquiteto de solução precisa entender. Ele precisa conversar. Ele precisa do vocabulário.
E o que eu quero dizer isso com você?
Hoje um arquiteto de solução muitas das vezes usa Ia, mas ele não sabe. Ia realmente lá. No nível baixo, por exemplo.
Você acha que toda arquitetolução sabe o que é um envol.
Beleza. Eu sei o que eu envolve, mas será que você sabe explicar? Seja.
Fez algo, né?
Então, assim.
é muito importante você entender essa separação.
Essa separação vai fazer você começar a pensar de formas diferentes. Então, enquanto o arquiteto da solução está pensando exatamente Nesse Processo Como Um Todo.
O que o engenheiro de Ia está pensando. Olha só o que o does dele significa.
Como que eu configuro a gente como que eu empacoto contexto.
Como que eu escrevo e vol. Como que eu enforço God Rames.
Cara. Esses quatro aqui, assassinos. Então, como que eu vou citar o meu processo? O meu Hardness.
Como que eu vou alimentar contexto. E eu vou falar para você. Já falei para todo mundo. Vou repetir aqui De Todos Os Anéis Qual O Anel Mais Importante Contexto.
Contexto, tá? Não só porque.
Ele traz o contexto do que você vai fazer.
Mas como? Onde é o ambiente em que você vai receber a qualidade dessa informação?
E ela vai derivar todos os outros anéis.
Se você olhar para todos os anéis agênticos que a gente já viu ao longo dessa semana, você vai ver Que O único Lugar Onde O Dado Reside é No Contexto.
Então o contexto é chave de tudo.
De tudo para o que o agente vai fazer.
Então, cara, entender o que você vai alimentar de contexto é extremamente crucial. Então assim.
Cara. Contexto passa muito tempo nisso aqui.
Escrever. E voz. Outra coisa muito importante. E voce são inscritos à mão. São validados pelo sistema Revows.
Ah, o que é um Invol de mentira? Na verdade, é porque.
Você consegue escrever voz depois do entendimento e observação do ambiente. Você não consegue escrever antes. Você pode ter uma Ideia Mais Ou Menos Mas Acontece Depois Da Validação.
Use Guardrails. Vocês vão aprender uma coisa aqui que vai explodir fora do país, que ainda não chegou no país, Mas Vai Chegar Vai Explodir No X Tá.
Que a gente chama de.
Finn, Hardness.
Fick Bound. Então, o que a gente está fazendo agora? A maioria das pessoas já entenderam que você tem que Entrar Lá Dentro Do Seu Repositório Que Você Tem.
Esteja fazendo e tirar noventa oitenta dos ridmes dos guardrais. Das coisas que você tem limpar.
Para deixar o sistema pensar muito bem, fazer o Reasoning que ele é bom nisso.
Só que tem um bounding que tem que ser muito grosso para te dar. Quais são os guardrails? Então a Gente Vai Ver Isso Durante A Semana Aqui Também Tá.
Então, olha só. Que interessante. O Model é o Cit, não, a decisão.
O Ival é quem julga.
A gente precisa ter prova.
Evidência, porque sem prova evidência, eu não consigo garantir que o Llm vai se comportar do jeito que eu espero.
Então eu preciso ter. Então pô, eu comecei um projeto. Eu não tenho evidência. Eu não tenho a prova cara saiba.
Que se você falar para o seu cliente ou para quem você esteja entregando, que vai completar um final.
Talvez não. Talvez você esteja mentindo para você e para essa pessoa.
Se precisa de saber o que é verdade. Antes de inicializar um processo agêntico.
E a ideia, literalmente, é acompanhar esse processo múltiplas vezes. Se tirar do loop.
Cada vez mais e evoluindo na cadeia.
Então está vendo que a gente está olhando coisas separadas aqui, né? Um arquiteto de solução está tentando identificar o que é Donny.
Um engenheiro de Ia. Está tentando entender como que eu provejo contexto.
Separado, tá? São coisas separadas.
Como que realmente eles pensam ali, né?
Então, cara. Uma queda de solução. Na prática, ele vai. Cara, pegar Spec vai pegar documento. Vai entender. Contrato. Vai tentar entender isso.
Do outro lado. O. A Engineer vai setar o ambiente como um todo. Então vai instalar os gaitways. Vai fazer conectividade com elime.
Vai, cara. Tem um rhidme bem configurado. Vai fazer make para ver se o ambiente tá rodando.
Vai fazer as configurações iniciais.
O que a gente quer garantir. Como um Solutions Architect, que a fonte pode mentir.
Então, cara, uma coisa é como eu consigo identificar quais são os processos críticos do ambiente. Um Solutions Architect precisa ter.
Essa mente investigativa. Como falaram aqui o arqueólogo.
Vai cavar. Vai perguntar. Vai estressar? Vai ver. Vai rever. Você tem tempo de cadeira aqui.
Você vai acelerar seu tempo com a. Mas não tira gente. Se vocês estão fazendo as coisas no automático, parem! Vocês Vão Entregar Bem, O Automático Já Aí é Muito Boa Se Você Der Um Pequeno Caminho Pra Ela.
Mas, cara, se você entender o problema que você está entender, os pormenores.
Cara. O nível de entrega que você faz é uma coisa assim.
Fora do mundo, sabe? Então usem isso ao seu favor.
Do outro lado. O que um Ea. Engineer sabe, cara chat é só chat. Ele precisa de contexto.
Ele precisa literalmente do entendimento. Ele precisa de um gráfico. Ele precisa de um Vector Database. Ele precisa de um Led.
Ele precisa de informações muito mais para isso.
You spot solução. Trabalham muito com classificação. Então a gente tem uma técnica quando a gente está lendo documento ou Entendendo Que é Classificar.
Usar classifiers ali. Cara, isso aqui é importante. Isso aqui é Bug. Isso aqui.
Você usa certas tags e você elege com a Llm certas tags.
Essas informações te ajudam um pouquinho. A identificar.
Certas características. Então você pode ler um documento e falar o seguinte. Olha.
Classifica e tags os pontos chaves, por exemplo.
Os Key items. Depois.
Verifica para mim. Se esse ski item são contraditórios dentro do documento, às vezes você acha coisas que falam assim.
Você tem que processar cem arquivos. Não sei o que, mas aí, depois, em uma parte do documento que é Enviado No E Mail Enfim.
Você tem outra informação que desclassifica aquela.
Então, o que você quer fazer? Você quer tentar entender aonde a fonte da verdade? Para gerar o quê? Aquela Evidência Para Poder Voltar Para O Cliente E Falar Olha Só.
Aqui foi falado dessa forma. Aqui foi falado dessa forma. Qual é a forma correta.
O que está correto, porque, cara, uma interpretação errada ou literalmente, o que acontece.
Se você entregar uma informação dessa. De uma arquiteto de solução transbordando.
But um ai Engineer posteriormente para o time que vai implementar. Isso pode lascar o projeto.
Então a ideia é que você preste atenção nesse tipo de coisa.
Então existem algumas perguntas que você faz padrão aí como Solutions Architect, como ai, Engineer.
Então, cara. Entender qual conceito? Identificar problema, literalmente navegar um arquivo para entender os formatos do arquivo, para poder gerar Um Requisito Muito Melhor.
O que funciona? Sucesso, o que é falha? Quais são os problemas de investigação? Quais são os problemas chaves que Você Tem No Sistema Atualmente.
Quais são os padrões que você tem assim por diante?
Do outro lado, a Engineer literalmente estruturar um bom repositório.
Criar um bom Cloud Md. Um bom Agents Md. Você tá. Quais são os.
As tecnologias e as técnicas que você vai usar para construir.
Se você vai ter um saco de brain, se você vai ter uma camada de ontologia que eu recomendo para Qualquer Projeto Desses Dois Principalmente A Camada De Ontologia Estava Inclusive Fazendo Hoje Uma Reunião Com A Ingenio.
Que é uma empresa americana. Para poder falar disso em Deep Dive. Todas as empresas fora do país estão procurando.
Contexto, todas, todas.
Empresas que eu converso, elas me chamam para falar de contexto.
Cara, beleza. A gente tem uma ideia de contexto, Miss Caro, com quem a gente operacionaliza o contexto, como que funciona.
Como que eu sei que uma informação é atual, a outra, ultrapassada.
Baseado no mesmo contexto, enfim.
Então estudem contexto. Contexto é extremamente importante para o nível Enterprise que vocês estão. Quanto mais você souber, melhor.
O que você pensa do processo como um todo. A gente vai usar Spectrum Development. Vai ser Intent Driven Development.
Como que vai ser o Workflow? Então? Ai, Engineer pensa muito no Workflow, pensando no chat ali, pô abrir o chat.
Como que é workflow desse processo? Como um todo.
Então a ideia é você trabalhar esse tipo de coisa.
Então, quando a gente olha o projeto hoje, o que que a gente tem, né?
A gente vai ver que a gente tem uma pasta chamada Spec, que é onde a gente vai guardar todas As Especificações Dos Tipos De Arquivo.
A gente tem contrato, que é literalmente nosso. Judge.
Então, por exemplo, pô, eu tenho o Sftp rodando no legado.
Eu tenho Sftp rodando no moderno. Pô. Quem vai julgar o que está certo ou está errado? O nosso contracts.
Então essa é uma das coisas que você tem que fazer nesse projeto de você, cara.
Qual a definição de correto? Tá aqui.
Beleza. Então, se eu estou criando os pipelines no final, eles têm que bater com contracts, então você cria uma validação.
Veja que todo esse repositório que eu criei é baseado numa técnica de você validar llms e trabalhar com llms. Tá.
Jane infraile Legacy. São frozen. Porque.
Eu já gero dado. Eu já tenho infraestrutura funcionando, e a minha infraestrutura alegada funciona. Enfim, enfim, então.
A gente não precisa modificar nada aqui.
Depois a gente tem validações com Test Treatment Development para validar que esse dado está correto.
A gente tem testes que são portões para permitir a gente avançar, para se tirar do loop. Cada vez mais, A Gente Vai Entrar Em Detalhes Aqui.
A gente tem o Make File, que é a superfície para a gente executar todos os comandos de bordo. Make File, unique.
Make file deploy make file run make file test. Então ele encapsula todos esses repositórios, todas essas pastas. Por isso Que Eu Adoro Make.
E as evidências como a gente viu. E a gente ainda não tem o Modern. Mas a gente vai construir Toda A Nossa Infraestrutura Na Quarta Feira Na Verdade Amanhã.
Como Java, como Soft engineer.
Pensando nisso, tá.
Então vamos dar uma olhadinha agora.
No dez, no onze.
Na verdade, nas duas partes do onze, vamos dar uma olhadinha.
Nessa navegação do que a gente vai entender sobre esse processo.
Então vamos aqui no dez, tá.
Então, como a gente viu aqui, né?
Os arquivos que são Frozen. Quais são as partes que podem ser mexidas ou não? Enfim.
Que que é ignorado.
E aí, o que que a gente tem é o State, né?
Então, olha só. Que interessante. O que que a gente vai fazer aqui? A gente vai começar a olhar. Quais são os documentos que nós temos disponíveis dentro do repositório. Para começar, essa tradução e entendimento.
Esse é o trabalho de um ai Engineergen Solutions. Architect.
Então, por exemplo, se eu vier aqui.
Né? No terminal.
E dê um Ls Spec Stage.
Então eu vou aqui. Ls. Specstate. O que que eu tenho aqui, né?
Eu tenho arquivos de e mail.
Eu tenho reuniões que foram feitas.
Eu tenho políticas da empresa.
Que estão colocadas aqui para a gente começar a entender como essa tradução e quais são as regras importantes do que.
Uma quieta solução. Vai ter que fazer, assim como o Ai Engineer.
Beleza. Então esse documento está aqui disponível.
Em. Esses documentos estão aqui em e mail. Meetings in Policies.
Aqui. Basicamente, a gente pode ter.
O que vocês quiserem.
Então isso aqui, basicamente, é a quantidade de documentos e arquivos que você vai ter dentro do projeto. Que você vai trabalhar.
Então, nesse caso, aí para vocês. Qual é a grande ideia? Pô, a grande ideia é, eu tenho meus transcripts Lá Das Reuniões. Eu Tenho minhas Conversas Do Slack. Eu Tenho Os Documentos De Levantamento De Requisito Enfim.
Então vou colocar isso dentro de um local para começar a fazer perguntas sobre isso. Entender o processo como um todo.
Então, o que a gente vai fazer aqui.
Como um Solutions Architect. Olha que legal! Então, como Solutions Architect, eu vou usar o mesmo contexto que eu estou Usando E Estou Falando O Seguinte.
Leu Ridme do Spec.
Do contrato e do Legacy.
Que aí vamos entender um pouquinho o que significa todos esses conteúdos, principalmente a do Spec.
Então ele vai dar uma leitura em cima disso. E aqui é olhando um pouquinho com a lente do Solutions, Architect.
Tá, deixa eu ver aqui. Como está o chat.
Started, as Dores. O que é o Lua? Hoje? Achei que só eu achava estranho essas soluções até testes da Data Bridge Dezanove Anos Jovens.
Produzes. Talvez não na estranho, não é? Loucuras.
Do mundo mesmo. Tá.
é.
Eu já vi. Tem Solutions, Engineers e Solutions. Architects.
Supostas são como framework.
Perfeito, Diego. Eu uso basicamente o mesmo esqueleto. Na maioria deles.
Boa pergunta. Qual a diferença de um teste para uma validação.
A gente vai. Eu não vou entrar em detalhes, porque vocês vão entender ao longo da semana.
Você pode ter certeza. Isso vai ficar extremamente.
Achatado na sua cara a diferença, então pode ficar tranquilo. Caio. E a Alan que a gente vai passar por esses dois aqui.
Beleza. ó, olha só li, né.
Olha só. Que interessante. O que é o System of Record?
Então, olha só.
A fonte, simulando as informações comitadas no Postgress.
Onde a Tabela de Legacy está escrita.
Source of observation. Então, system of Record. é o Pulsory.
é literalmente onde as informações estão.
Source of observation.
São os arquivos que são imutáveis. Ou seja, eles não podem mudar.
Então, que são os arquivos Sftp.
O que é Source of Correctness.
São os arquivos que são revisados via Csv e a reconciliação.
Que garante realmente a verdade.
Então três coisas que você quer sempre tentar achar. Quando você cria um sistema.
é Season of Record.
Sistemas agênticos tá source of observation.
And source of correctness.
Então a ideia é você sempre tentar achar esses três.
Common System of Records, Common Systems Observation common source.
Of correctness, tá, então a ideia é a gente tentar achar esses três caras.
Isso vai dar uma visão básica do que a gente precisa para construir um sistema agêntico que vai funcionar. Fim A Fim Muito Bem.
A gente já sabe o que é um Frozen. Então eles estão congelados ali para não serem editados. Ou pelo Menos Existe Essa Regra Obviamente Que Eles Podem Porque Não Foi Forçado Isso.
Então, o que significa cada um? O Legacy.
Então são as informações do oraco, as migrações, tudo que é feito.
Contratos. Quais são os valores? Enfim, Ah, não. Mas você só está falando superficialmente. Fica tranquilo.
Amanhã com a lente de engenheiro de software. A gente vai ter que vir aqui.
Na parte maravilhosa de Legacy.
A gente vai ter que abrir processo.
A gente vai ter que abrir, Src. A gente vai ter que abrir.
Java com nove Windpay Legacy Type One. E a gente vai ter que literalmente ver.
Esse cara. Como ele trabalha.
Mas na lente de um engenheiro de software.
E de um Ai Needs of Engineer. Como a gente vai abordar isso.
Porque, por exemplo, eu não sei.
Isso aqui. Como que a gente faz para entender.
Então a gente vai navegar nisso amanhã. Aqui a gente está olhando como arquiteto de solução.
Beleza. A gente não está olhando.
Como um engenheiro de software.
Está olhando como arquiteto de solução hoje.
Beleza. Então eu tenho as informações, Frozen. O que significa cada um, né? Então, Legacy.
Tudo que está ali relacionado ao ambiente.
Onde é que são os valores que são esperados? Espera que são os arquivos que a gente recebe para fazer a tradução.
Então, dentro do Spec. Aqui a gente tem o tipo. Um tipo dois, tipo três, quatro, tipo cinco. A gente vai receber.
Esse pacote de informações. Pô, vocês precisam traduzir o Java.
Para Python, por exemplo, me passa os documentos. Quais são os documentos que eu vou ter.
Então a gente vai ver amanhã. Quais são os documentos que eu vou receber? Eu vou receber cem. Vou receber inbounding.
Eu vou receber arquivos de output para poder verificar isso. E a gente vai passar pelo nível de tradução. Para isso.
Então, basicamente, essa primeira parte.
Na parte de um Aiider Engineer. O que que a gente quer fazer.
Vamos dar uma olhadinha em todos os Folders.
Para cada. Vamos ver se a gente pode ter um agente que vai ler, que vai escrever, ou qualquer um deles, né? Vamos Tentar Entender O Que A Gente Vai Fazer Na Perspectiva De Um Ai Engineer.
E por último, a gente vai perguntar o que é uma evidência. Como a gente já perguntou anteriormente.
Já vou botar aqui. O que é uma evidência.
Depois, como a turma é acelerada, vou colocar.
Abriu Spec State Cover Md.
E tratar isso como e mail e não tratar como um contrato. Na verdade, só para ler esse cara.
Então o primeiro que a gente vai fazer é listar os níveis de top level do repositório. Então a gente quer entender.
Basicamente o que cada um significa aqui.
Beleza.
Tá puxando, ó tá vindo! E no nosso isso a gente vai executar esses três aqui para ir para o próximo.
Então, vamos lá.
Deixa ele escrever aqui alguma dúvida? Por enquanto? Sangue de Cristo tem poder.
Para o que você falou. Isso no japa, né? Beleza.
A gente for falar de políticas, né?
Os acessos que a gente tem.
Em todos eles de leitura. Não existe nada bloqueado.
Então, enquanto.
Write Nothing Frozen.
A gente viu aqui que não tem nada. Literalmente.
A ideia é explicar o que é, né?
Em Bondings. Contratos.
Gerador, infraestrutura, legado, validações, testes unitários.
Planos agenda do dia.
Todas execução, fim a fim.
Apresentação, os decks e apresentação usáceitas às imagens, documentação.
Brain que a gente já vê. Um College que a gente já vê. Evidência e Modern tá.
Beleza. O que é uma evidência? A gente viu lá.
Rodar por pacote, garantir que esse cara vai funcionar na sua máquina.
E que literalmente, você tem os valores que batem definidos a um arquivo, alguma coisa que vai ser escrito dentro De Um Bet Dentro De Um Arquivo Chamado Reconciliation Json.
Para isso que a gente tem. E a última pergunta.
Ele pediu para a gente abrir o Spec State Cover Spec State.
Cover aqui. ó.
Esse cover, né?
é literalmente as informações lá da Helena.
Que ela tinha enviado via e mail.
Onde ela explica basicamente o que a gente quer fazer.
A gente não precisa. A gente não deve substituir o Java. Muito pelo contrário. A gente tem que criar uma perna.
A mais para o sistema.
A ideia é a gente conseguir controlar esse processo inteiro via contrato, porque a gente já tem um contrato que Foi Feito A Gente Vai Avaliar Ao Longo Dos Dias.
O que esse contrato significa e assim por diante. Tá.
Então, basicamente, isso.
Beleza. Então, três coisas. Temos cover Md, né? Que é literalmente a aprovação.
De que a gente vai começar a trabalhar esse projeto.
E a gente tem o Steel Thread. Vocês vão ler muito sobre isso na área de engenharia ou.
Isso é normal acontecer. As ellielines cospem muito isso. Quando você estiver trabalhando com essa parte de decomposição.
O que é um Steel thread.
And we still thread é o mínimo viável de uma execução que é extremamente loading, o que é um load Bearing Que é Extremamente Crucial Para O Sistema é Um Load Bearing.
Então, nesse caso, aqui a gente tem uma validação que é o Valid Minimal.
Que bateu. Lembra que a gente executou. Então esse é um Steel Thread. Uma Steel thread é algo extremamente pequeno Que Vai Provar Um Ponto Muito Importante.
Então, por exemplo, card settlement. O que você quer fazer? Você quer garantir que o valor bate lá da fonte Com O Destino Enfim.
Então o que você vai fazer? Você vai criar um puta.
Processo complexo. Não, isso não é um Steel Threat. O que é um Steel Thread? é algo pequeno que vai validar esse cara.
Beleza. Agora, como que a gente vai abordar esse processo.
é aí que vem a parte interessante de tudo isso.
E como a gente aborda, Mindset, é aqui que vem.
Aqui que eu digo aqui que vem a parte do dia.
Extremamente importante do dia de hoje.
Que até agora, a gente navegou, investigou, começou a trabalhar com Brown Field. Setor ambiente.
Validou o ambiente de intenção, viu evidência, executou o ambiente, fim a fim.
Agora a gente vai começar a agir no processo.
Então tres coisas que a gente vai passar aqui.
Agora muito importantes. Tá.
A primeira é o Second Brain.
Todo projeto que eu começo todos eles, tá, eu tenho cerco de Brain.
E aí eu tenho um cycle de Brain. Meu.
Sobre as minhas coisas.
Que tem as informações dos projetos.
Mas eu recomendo você ter um Seconds Brain por projeto.
Então a ideia é você ter um por projeto? Ah, não. Eu quero ter um para todos os projetos.
Ok, sem problemas. Eu recomendo ter separado.
Por vários motivos. O primeiro motivo é para reduzir a alucinação. Segundo motivo é pelo crescimento.
Terceiro motivo é que cada tipo de informação que você coloca requer uma forma diferente de organizar essa informação em escala.
Então vou dar um exemplo: pô se no projeto A. Você recebe muito e mail e muito transcript.
Talvez no projeto B, você receba muito e mail, muito transcript, mas ainda muito mais documento solto.
Ainda muito mais thread de Slack, ainda muito mais print de imagem. E essas informações, elas são tratadas de formas diferentes.
Então colocar tudo isso dentro do mesmo bolo vai dificultar.
A sua consulta ao longo prazo.
Então a ideia é a gente criar literalmente o quê? Um Second Brain do projeto.
Existem várias formas de fazer isso.
E de forma simples. O que é um Second de Brain.
Nada mais é do que um contexto vivo. Para que você trabalhe com o projeto. Numa camada acima.
Então pensar num arquiteto de solução, pensando no Ai Engineer, que ainda não está codando.
Quite. A ideia dele tem o contexto do projeto. Entender sobre o projeto como um todo. Tá.
Aqui. Nesse caso, a gente vai utilizar o notebook. Lm.
Para poder fazer. Não, não é o Cloud Md. O Cloud Md são as instruções que você passa para os Agentes Utilizarem Durante A Execução.
O século de Breen é literalmente você pegar todos os documentos que você recebe do projeto que você tem.
Colocar isso dentro de um local e usar uma Illn para fazer essas perguntas. Tá.
Então, o que a gente vai fazer? A gente vai aqui no doze.
Eu quero foto, tá? Quem fizer.
Que essa é a parte legal do rolê.
Então, bombinha, aqui.
Doze.
Second Brain. Então a gente vai, na verdade, utilizar o Pack Brain notebook, North Windpay, Brain, Zip.
Para poder executar esse cara.
Então, o que a gente vai fazer.
A gente vai dentro do notebook.
Então, para quem nunca usou o notebook? Lm: Quem nunca usou o notebook? Lm: Fala eu aqui só para saber Se Tem Alguém Que Nunca Usou O Notebook Lm.
Legal.
Eu uso o Codex ou o Cloud. Tá? Eu coloquei aqui o Jim Nine Notebook porque ele é Free.
Então por causa disso, tá? E ele é muito bom pra isso. Na verdade, tá. Eu, na minha humilde opinião, como.
Como reggae e como sistema para fazer pesquisas. Assim.
Eu acho. Jamming notebook melhor do que todos disparadamente. Tá.
Então vocês vão acessar o notebook Google com.
Então vamos lá. Edgebook, ponto, Google, ponto com.
Beleza novo notebook. Vamos chamar de Northwind Pay.
Então vou chamar esse notebook novo notebook.
Vou chamar ele de fechar aqui.
Chamar ele de North Windpay.
Beleza. Chamei de North Windpay.
Cara. Leva cinco minutos. Isso aqui, né? Olha só. Que foda.
Você vai fazer um zip.
Do arquivo que vai ter todas as informações do projeto que a gente tem. Então.
Na prática, aqui, seria basicamente entender todos os conteúdos e contextos do projeto.
Que a gente tem. Então a gente vai trazer aqui fazer um zip desse zip.
Agora vamos ver se a gente consegue já importar como Zip. Eu não sei. Então vamos vir aqui em.
Adicionar fonte.
Vamos em upload. File.
E daí? A gente vai lá dentro do local onde a gente está. Que é Git?
O ser no film wind pay.
Aí a gente vai em Brain.
Could the brain. A gente vai em notebook.
E aqui. ó, a gente não tem. ó.
Acesso ao Zip. Mas.
Todos esses arquivos aqui que já estão. São eles.
Vamos dar um Open.
Vamos ingerir todos esses documentos aqui dentro.
Beleza tá aqui.
Disponível. Eu quero foto, tá.
Eu quero ver se as pessoas estão me acompanhando.
A gente fez esses caras. Adicionou todos eles.
Inserimos todos os conteúdos.
Agora a gente vai começar a fazer algumas perguntas para o meu Secundem Brain. Aí sim, Henrique.
Porra! E sim aí, ó.
Bruno tá acompanhando. Boa, Bruno feliz. Tá acompanhando, Top.
Mais quem? Só dois. Gente.
Okay, did it now.
Ok, tá aí. Foi boa.
Agora a gente vai fazer perguntas para o meu Second de Brain.
Aí. Você fala. Pô isso aí que você fez, idiota. Não, isso aqui é foda, velho, porque agora você tá.
Consolidando tudo num lugar só. Tá?
Então, o que é, Helena? Dias, né.
O que ela perguntou sobre modernização para a gente fazer.
E o que está fora do escopo? Olha só, porra! Temos um Sacer de Brand com texto.
Para responder sobre nossas perguntas, sobre o projeto.
Então. Ok, Helena, dias. Ela é padre integration requisitando projeto passa aqui. Quais são os documentos que ele achou.
Ela é responsável por ver um shared folder, blá, blá, blá.
O que ela pediu para a modernização. Ela requisitou.
Quem já fazia isso no projeto.
Coloca quem não fazia isso nos projetos. Coloca eu quem ia lá na Tora. Pegava os documentos, saía pesquisando, enfim.
Qualquer. Eu não fazia cara. Vocês vão sentir uma puta diferença, velho.
Uma puta diferença, tá.
Muito. Tá.
Qual a vantagem do notebook? Lm: Não poderia criar uma pasta no projeto? Ou pergunta muito boa pergunta.
Ives.
Lembra que aqui a gente está com a lente do arquiteto de solução.
Like. A solução. Normalmente, ele não trabalha dentro do repositório.
Então, o que você quer ter sempre? Você quer ter uma base fora do repositório.
Porque literalmente, onde você vai fazer reunião? Você vai trazer o transcript para casa. Vai começar com a galera.
Você vai injetar a informação. Você vai fazer um negócio. Você vai trazer o processo, entendeu?
Então essa é a grande ideia.
Pela perspectiva, literalmente, do contexto. Isso é uma fora as outras fora a qualidade do que roda por debaixo de um notebook llm.
é.
Você tem algumas vantagens aqui da Google em relação a isso. Como eles fazem reggae? Como eles destenchem essa informação.
Você consegue criar audiobook aqui? Você consegue gerar slide.
Consegue criar overviews consegue fazer flashcard quiz mind map. Então.
Você tem uma série de benefícios aqui, tá? Mas principalmente porque você está fora do contexto.
Você não vai estar no repositório. Eu deixei no repositório para a gente poder importar e ser mais fácil.
Mas na vida real, vai vir externo. Essa informação.
Boa.
Show. A galera tá indo, hein?
Boa. Gostando de ver, cara. Que massa!
Boa. Vamos lá, beleza. Então.
O que está fora do escopo. Alguns elementos são especificamente desenhados. Alguns estão fora do escopo. Por exemplo, o Tipo Seis Foi Falado Que Está Fora Do Escopo.
Olha só. Que coisa foda do notebook. Lm: Ele te traz exatamente o local onde foram feitas referências. Isso é Rag.
Funcionando.
Edital substituir.
O Legacy passe o modelo Lake House. Isso não é provido. A gente vai ter que.
Fazer? A gente não mexe nos contracts.
Os rodos Sample são tipos de arquivos que são definidos na definição desse cara.
Então, aqui a gente tem algumas informações. Depois. Olha só.
Vamos tentar começar a entender agora sobre os tipos, né?
Denomem os cinco arquivos que a gente tem.
Quais são eles? Tá uma linha para cada. E o que é o Tipo seis? Vamos ver aqui o que ele vai trazer.
Então, assim não sei se você percebeu. O primeiro passo foi humano. Agora a gente está utilizando llm.
Para você literalmente entender o contexto e entender exatamente o que está sendo feito. Então, olha só. Que interessante.
Deixa eu começar a navegar nesse cara.
E aí se tornem muito.
Muito animados para entender o problema. Navegar.
Perguntar, digerir. é isso que vai fazer você construir uma solução fudida no final, com a gente, tá.
Antigamente, a gente não tinha tempo para fazer isso como engenheiros. Hoje a gente tem tempo. Tá.
Então construído baseado nisso, quais são os cinco tipos? O tipo, um Accord settlement.
Tá que é fixo. Depois a gente tem o Type Two, que é instant Payment, que é um Pipe Delimited, ou seja.
Veja que um é fixed Ed.
O outro é Pipe the Limit. Um é iso, o outro é Utf.
Tá. Então são diferentes. Txt.
Tipo três Payment Slips Legacy.
As que encode. Rain, caralho, que nab is file.
Beleza. Type Four, Ted Asking Code.
E Type Five Mission Fees.
Csv. Ou seja, eu trouxe três problemas completamente diferentes e complexos, com tipos de utf podings diferentes, com técnicas diferentes Para A Gente, Trabalhar.
Para a gente ver como vai comportar ali. Que foda diferentes formas, tá.
E o que é o Tipo seis? O tipo seis? Na verdade, é um arquivo completamente fora de escopo.
Que não foi revelada, que só será feito na sexta feira.
E ele possivelmente vai ter um Red Pill ou Une kit, que a gente vai ter que entender.
Ao longo do trabalho. Beleza.
Show!
Terceira pergunta.
Que Donny significa.
Então está vendo aqui? Eu como Solutions Architect, para poder criar o meu plano para a minha equipa assim por Diante Eu Estou Explorando.
Trabalhando, ou seja.
Você é o arquiteto de solução que irá construir planos para seus agentes trabalharem.
Beleza.
Então é isso então, beleza. ó Under North Windpay modernization Specification Donny.
Tem um has very strict zero Tolerance Definition.
Então, arquivos sanitizados.
Boundaries de privacidade, tolerância. A gente não pode ter nenhum tipo de problema, né?
But playing tem que ser estabilizado. Eu não posso ter aqui. Você ident.
Que são escritas na Stage ou nas tabelas de legado.
é.
Eu tenho que identificar quais são os problemas que são feitos.
Que são encontrados.
O dado nunca pode ser reparado ou alterado. Ou seja, ele é literalmente desculpa, canônico. Não, ele é imutável. Aqui tá.
Então essas são as informações de não.
Literalmente do que da onde significa.
Beleza. Vamos entrar no conceito que eu falei do Steel Thread.
What is type zero one physically encoding record Shapes Overpunch site da Layout. Olha que massa. Agora a gente vai Boom.
Navegar no tipo um pra entender.
Show. Tipo um court settlement encode and offline. Lf.
Estrutura. One header.
O ano. More details in one trailer. Então ele tem um cabeçalho.
Vários. Um ou vários detalhes e um trailer de confirmação.
Tá. Qual o Shape dele? Então?
De um. A posição é o record Id.
De dois a nove. Ele é o File Dates de dez a vinte e cinco. Ele é o Bet Id.
De vinte e seis a treze e sete. é o layout Code.
Que é o tipo de sério de um.
E de treze e oito a catorze. Ele é a versão na posição do Header.
Beleza dos Detail. Como que ele faz isso? Record Id, Transaction, Id, machine.
Que o Primary Account Number Cpf.
Transaction date Time amount.
Com cobal overpunt, né? Currency.
Movement out code.
An su terminal e o trailer como ele é definido record Id para fechar.
Data. Detail Count net counts com Kobo overpunt Bet Id.
E aí ele explica aqui qual o nível de kob over punching que ele faz, né?
Então os níveis numéricos de pós dezassete e cinto e oitenta e seis trailer.
Que codifica o valor.
Então ele tem da escala negra do zero mais.
Para o mais nove e dos negativos do menos zero para o menos nove. Então exemplos. Então, o que isso aqui seria.
Zero, zero, zero, zero, um, dois, três, quatro e mapeia. Um, dois, três, quarenta e cinco. é.
Vale cinco, por exemplo.
Um, dois, três. M, mapeia para menos doze, trinta e cinco. Deixe que M representa negativo.
No final. Quatro.
Então, aqui tem algumas informações e técnicas sobre isso. Beleza.
Uh.
Eu estava respondendo em português. Nada começou em inglês, Luan. Se o cliente Team stakeholder quiser ter isso, para entender Também O Projeto Que Sugere.
O século de Bre acaba ficando pessoal. Tem alguma coisa para time ou deixa Git indicada.
Tem gente que compartilha. Por exemplo, o Jeff Deverter, que é o Field que eu trabalho junto. A gente compartilha o mesmo.
O mesmo notebook. Lm.
Então ele faz uma coisa muito legal que eu costumo fazer. Por exemplo, eu vou viajar agora na sexta feira Que Vem Eu Vou Para.
Para Cleveland. Eu vou ministrar. Segunda, terça e quarta. Então, o que a gente faz? A gente pega o Plods.
Eu não sei se vocês conheçam Plods. Tem gente que não conhece.
Mas eu pego o Plots que eu tenho.
E basicamente, eu ligo o Plod.
Ou por esse dispositivo que eu tenho. Esse o plod not pins.
Basicamente, eu ligo ele e aí eu falo a reunião inteira.
It is aí no final da reunião, eu desligo. Ele.
Ele pega essas informações transcripta eles, né.
E daí? Ele manda para o meu notebook. Lm.
Então, depois dos terceiros dias, eu faço umas coisas muito legais. Por exemplo, eu fiz a aula na segunda feira.
E aí os clientes falaram e tal. Peguei feedback. Não sei o que.
Aí na terça feira.
Geralmente eu faço de madrugada as apresentações de três h às cinco da manhã. Enfim, quando eu estou fora.
E daí? Eu já pego os updates. O que a galera falou? Eu já coloco no outro dia por causa dele.
Então eu já tenho esse tipo de coisa. Funciona bem, bem, legal. Eu uso bastante.
E aí? Lá tem uma política.
De que pode usar plods para tudo. Então, nas reuniões, a gente usa.
E cara. Faz uma diferença muito foda pelo contexto. E a gente injeta todo esse notebook. Lm.
Lua. Deixa eu colocar código fontes para confrontar o que realmente está escrito em confronto, que passaram documentação.
Não, eu uso mais ele como a minha fonte de permitar navegar, destilar.
Muitas das vezes. Por exemplo, eu vou viajar. Eu estou no avião. O que eu faço tá? Só para vocês Entenderem Uma Das Minhas Técnicas.
Eu venho aqui, cara. Crio um áudio Overview, salvo esse cara e vou no ipad escutando. Quando eu tô no avião.
Então eu gosto muito disso. Eu faço muito isso quando eu estou viajando.
Eu gero vários áudios e vou escutando.
Para poder ingerir. E é perfeito. O áudio do notebook. Lm: é o melhor. Na verdade, já tentei. Eleven Labs. Já Tentei Um Bocado De Coisa Muito Bom.
Então eu uso para contexto.
Beleza. E temos mais. O quê?
Delay, tá, vamos ver aqui.
O que significa um the source lie what does the type zero on thriller. Declare.
What does The detail Row at.
And what must be the new plan not to do.
Das marinas. Say the same shape exists on picks is lipstead and feast.
Pelo tipo um Source Lie.
O file metadait transaction detail quebrados da seguinte forma.
Naquele problema do Source Line, onde a gente teve um que a gente vai investigar, que é um problema.
O que o trailer declara naquele tipo de evidência que a gente ainda não viu. A gente vai ver ao longo do treinamento.
Ele declara Net Amount de cento e setenta e três, quarenta e quatro.
Mas na verdade, no Detail, quando você vai somar fazer o roll set up?
O que ele faz é, na verdade, ele faz cento e setenta e três, quarenta e cinco.
Então, qual é o grande negócio aqui, né?
A gente tem. A validação funciona, mas o número não está correto. Beleza.
O que a Marina fala sobre isso. A Marina é explicitamente fala.
Que essa discrepância de identidade é um padrão que ocorre no Pix.
His sleep e Machine fez. E aí, ó, isso aqui é muito foda.
Ele cita onde? Então esse aqui é importante.
Então você dampa um bocado de lugar. Ele vai te citar.
Cara para mim aí, Luana, o melhor reggae que existe pra esse tipo de coisa é o do notebook. Lm: é O Na Verdade O Jamie é Muito Bom Pra Isso.
Eu uso Gemini para codar, mas para Reg. Pra esse tipo de coisa aqui não conheço nada melhor, de verdade, Qualidade Assim Eu Já Testei Algumas Coisas.
Mas eu acho ele muito bom. Tá.
Então aqui, por exemplo, no e mail do Julho, catorze, dois mil e vinte e seis.
Card settlement I aqui, ok? é a nossa evidência.
Declara cento e sessenta e três, quarenta e quatro. Nosso detalhe adicionou cento e setenta e três, quarenta e cinco.
O mesmo estilo Sleep.
Também façam isso. A gente tem um acesso indefied zero noventa e nove versus um.
Né.
If your new plant quietly rights centre.
We have nothing to show the source keep their numbers refuse the batch this is the whole point.
Então a ideia é que o nosso sistema não deve consertar esse tipo de problema. Ele deve identificar o problema.
Porque esse é o mesmo comportamento que a gente tem no sistema. Foda, estamos entendendo? Tem o ambiente.
Navegando duas procs there are two stories for the procks with two dates for types zero one.
Which one does Raphael say to use.
Existem duas histórias possíveis pro. Tipo um. Você está aí identificando, navegando.
Maio de dois mil e doze. Você tem um cara chamado Serumant dois mil e vinte e seis cinco doze. Você Tem O Settlement Dois Mil E Vinte E Seis Sete Onze.
Qual usar. Rafael Costa. Se precisa instruir que o time vai usar a partir de Julho de dois mil e Vinte E Seis Tal.
O que está incorreto. The main proceeds concluir outdated.
And it has two primary issues tem dois problemas aqui. O problema é ignorar os Refundes, os refunds.
Pelo negativo Overpunt. Então tem um problema que tem que ser maior do que zero.
It was damped by mistake.
Ah, tá. Ele dampou uma versão desotualizada que não deveria estar lá.
Tá.
Beleza.
Um guinhua.
Quero passar com tudo para vocês.
O que não está nas três fontes.
Ai, que legal! Mas olha que legal!
Márcia já criou aqui uma visão.
Muito foda. Olá.
Ouvir, Punch. Declaração do trailer.
Midwall.
Cara é muito massa trabalhar em equipe. Eu me sinto agora trabalhando em equipe. De certa forma.
é legal. Fazia tempo que eu não passava por isso.
Mas é um bom tempo, na verdade.
Beleza que ele fala basicamente dos componentes explícitos do que está do contrato do tipo seis. Mas a gente tem uma boa ideia.
Um bom Starting Point.
Beleza. Então, antes da gente seguir.
Já está acabando. Continua aqui. Já estamos até onze quatorze. Então aguenta mais trinta minutos e a gente acaba.
Pergunta para você. Muito importante. Todo mundo entendeu. Aqui coloca sim.
Temos cento e vinte e um pessoas interajam comigo. Aí me falem.
Deu para entender.
Importância de um Second Brain porque você tem que ter esse cara. Consequentemente.
Obrigado, galera. Muito obrigado.
Agora a gente vai para uma camada abaixo.
Aí. Aqui é legal.
Aqui é uma parada agressiva.
Aqui a gente está falando de camada ontológica.
Tá? Então a gente vai dar o que agora?
Significado.
Sobre o Ddl na base.
Então, o que significa essa definição de store? Procedure para o negócio.
Então, o que o Ontolayer, que está disponível para vocês, que na verdade é um projeto que o Rafa fez Inicialmente Existem Vários Né.
é a camadas de ontologia. O Rafa criou um Toulayer justamente para poder.
Fazer toda essa parte de melhoria e enriquecimento do dado em diferentes fontes de dados. Isso está dentro do repositório E A Gente Vai Ver Agora.
Então, a ideia é que a gente vai fazer o Crowley.
Do postgress. A gente vai escanear. Esquema, tabela, coluna.
é ficar view store. Procedure. Enfim.
E vai entender os significados dessa informação. E vai criar um Mcp de conexão com isso. Então, na prática, como você deve fazer.
Cara, se você puder. A ideia é você entrar nas suas fontes de dados.
Trazer essas informações para uma camada ontológica de metadado.
E aí, na hora que o agente vai pesquisar a informação, ele não vai nela. Ela vai na sua camada ontológica.
Porque a camada ontológica vai dar o quê? Sentido à informação.
Então a gente vai entender. Por exemplo, qual a ligação.
Entre.
Qual a ligação entre as entidades.
Que significa pago por onde ele passa.
O que ele faz. Por que ele faz? Quais são as tabelas que ele toca? Quais são as rotinas.
Que são relacionadas.
Colocar aqui.
Vai estar fechado. Vocês não vão ter acesso, mas está dentro do repositório. Então relaxa, que eu vou mostrar agora.
Então vamos dar uma olhadinha.
Na ontologia. E por que ela é foda, então não é só entender ontologia, tá?
Então vamos lá. Por que ontologia, né?
Então vamos ver. Vamos acessar aqui o repositório.
Então vamos voltar lá para esse cara.
Quatrocentos e quatro. Porque está no repositório? Tá.
Então aqui, ó, vamos ler o Ontology. Ontology.
Tá vendo? Tá tudo aqui. Então vamos ler o Ontology Rhydme.
E identificar o que é ontology.
O que que ele varre.
E o que não faz, tá.
Então, vamos lá.
De forma bem curta. A ontologia é um catálogo.
Sobre o North Wind.
Portugues. Depois de um Make Deploy.
Então, o que ele vai fazer ele fazer o crowlling da informação? Colunas eficazes, store procedures e vai entender o significado desse cara.
Então, basicamente, se a gente vê em Reading aqui.
Ele vai escanear essas informações. Então você vai conectar esse cara ao Postgress.
E a gente vai fazer um Deployment dessas informações. Existem vários features aqui para vocês verem e identificarem.
He's versão das partes do processo. Também.
E você pode perguntar assim.
Rapaz, Juliana. Tá sofrendo aí, hein.
Gente. Vocês escutaram. Não escutem. Um projeto de ontologia está dentro do repositório aqui que vocês já têm.
Ali é o projeto que o Rafa criou. Eu trouxe esse projeto para dentro do nosso repositório dentro. Aqui.
Do Folder. Ontology.
Então aqui ele explica basicamente o que significa para o sistema gêntico, né?
Vamos entender aqui o que é uma camada de ontologia, né.
Puxar aqui o conceito. Eu quero que vocês entendam. ó.
Em a ontologia significa algo explícito, compartilhado de especificação num domínio.
Como aquelas coisas se relacionam. Então, por exemplo.
Se você tem um domínio de finanças, você quer entender o significado, então você olha o banco de dados, você entende a estrutura.
E o que significa? Mas o significado em cima dessa informação no nível negócio.
é ontologia que faz.
Então, quando você olha, por exemplo, isso vem de mil novecentos e noventa e três.
Onde você tinha agentes compartilhando informações com sinalização. Aí vocês vão ler.
O que a gente especifica dentro de uma ontologia.
Ontologia específica. Tipo, quais são os tipos de coisas? Se é um Bet, se é um Mechchan, se é uma reconciliação.
Ele especifica a relação como ele se correlacionam. O que escrita? O que se relaciona? Qual é o grão.
Ele tem propriedades.
Ele tem constraints. Quais são os processos? O que significa staging.
Qual é a combinação de Bad Id mais currency assim por diante?
Então aqui tem taxonomia. é uma árvore ontologia é o significado das informações.
Knowledge Graph.
é uma.
é um esquema populado com.
é o dado populado com esquema instâncias.
Camada semântica. Tá.
é o que significa uma métrica, por exemplo, de revenue. E aí você consegue adicionar isso na ontologia. Também.
E contexto por Llm. é um pedaço da informação. Então dá o contexto por Llm e falar. Leia o Post Greens é Uma Coisa.
A camada ontológica te dá o significado das informações e relações que a gente vai ver exatamente agora.
Quando a gente fizer uma pesquisa. Então lemos e tal, né?
Agora o que um toler é, né? A gente leu ontologia. O que o ontoleiro.
Volto ler. é exatamente o que essa forma de a gente pegar essas informações e utilizar os sistemas agênicos para fazer isso.
Ou se a gente vê aqui, por exemplo.
Vocês podem navegar aqui, tá?
Em como é feito. Mas aqui existem todo o processo.
Motoleira. Um upstream Crowley.
Que vai fazer o Crowler do Postress.
E aí, nesse caso, a gente configurou esse simples de configuração para o Post. Você pode configurar para outras coisas.
O que utiliza por debaixo dos panos um Open search com enriquecimento de llm.
Para poder fazer o quê? Ler essas informações do Database e tentar melhorar essas informações. Para dar significado.
Então, olha só.
Isso aqui é importante. Why do we ask the graph instead of grappling Legacy Postquers.
Então, qual a diferença de eu fazer um Graph que no arquivo.
Com a diferença de eu fazer literalmente uma pesquisa via ontologia.
E aqui a gente vai entender a diferença.
ó quando eu faço cem.
O que que a Llm vai fazer, né?
Ele vai lá no Skn. Ele literalmente vai ver o State. Então, se eu chegar, por exemplo, pra Lerm e falar.
Leia.
Assist procedure put it in.
Beleza. Ele vai ler. Store, procedure.
Mas ele não tem contexto. Ele vai entender o que é, mas ele não tem um contexto.
Com o.
Ontology. Você pode fazer uma pesquisa.
E essas informações vão estar armazenadas, por exemplo, num Led, ou dentro de um reggae. Para você fazer essa informação enriquecida via.
Metatado. Então você tem um metadado em cima disso, tá.
Por exemplo, se eu fizer uma pesquisa. Stage Apply Write transaction Id.
Ai. Olha só. Period is observed on reporting card Settlement Reconciliation. Veja o seguinte.
Quando eu perguntei, vimcp.
Desculpa. Quando eu perguntei. Sem.
Ontologia. Basicamente, ele me deu uma resposta do que significa.
Pô Staging a Paid Apply Rights Reporting Green transaction Id.
Quando você tem ontologia, ele identifica.
A relação. Então, cara.
Pagamento observado na Store procedure, tal.
Por essa característica.
O grão aqui é inventado porque ele não sabe qual é o grão.
Nesse caso, aqui a gente tem o Bet Id Currency. Porque nós falamos. Qual grão.
Então a gente vai ver que existe uma diferença de você pesquisar uma informação pedindo uma Llm lá, e olhar Arquivos E Tentar Identificar O Que Que é.
Do que você constar uma ontologia e ter certeza, literalmente, do que significa naquele seu domínio.
Então, por exemplo.
Mesmo a questão.
Vamos ver aqui. ó.
Vamos pegar isso aqui. ó.
Where Does Speed Live. Então, onde o pagamento vive? Para o tipo de um card settlement.
Nome deu os nomes das tabelas de report grão.
Qual o proceder, está.
Então eu tô perguntando isso aqui.
Sem esse cara.
Vou perguntar a ele. Literalmente, sem nada.
Eu vou vir aqui.
Vou fazer uma pergunta direto na Elen. Essa pergunta direta na llm beleza.
Depois pra ele mapear tudo.
Obviamente que isso aqui é um dataset, né? é um sistema pequeno.
Então ele vai conseguir achar algumas relações. Talvez boa parte das relações.
Mas imagina isso numa casa gigantesca de bases de telas e terabytes de dados.
Lembra que a gamologia estava explicando hoje? Ela não tem um dado. Ela tem um metadado, um enriquecimento da informação. Então é Isso Que Eu Quero Que Vocês Entendam.
Agora, o que a gente vai fazer.
No dois. A gente vai.
Conectar.
A ontologia e vai fazer uma pesquisa no nível ontologia.
Mas aí, montar ontologia de forma funcional, num grande projeto complexo, né?
Sim.
é complexo, mas nem tanto complexo. Assim, existem algumas formas de como a gente vai fazer isso em grande escala.
Tem processos para a gente fazer.
Dá um bom trabalho para criar, mas traz um resultado inimaginável.
Então aqui, ó, vamos fazer.
Um make ontontology e um make ontontology Graph.
Vou abrir aqui.
Make ontology Make Ontology Ask. E eu vou fazer uma pesquisa agora na ontologia.
Vmcp.
Boa, Julian.
Estamos comemorando com você.
Então aqui o que seria um Make on Politics? Tá vendo o que ele fez? ó.
Ele fez uma pesquisa. Achou vinte e um tabelas, as entidades Foreign Keys. Enfim. E aí, o que ele fez.
Ele consegue achar as relações das coisas.
Então, por exemplo, reporting table court Settlement. Qual grão.
Beth Id currency. Quais são os paid facts applied count applied net amount status.
Escreve em qual tabela aplica, onde não está. Então essas relações de conexão.
Ele faz beleza.
Eu vou falar ao longo da semana. Mas a ideia é você investigar aqui dentro de Ontology. Tem tudo aqui.
Então você tem todo o escopo mais importante da camada de ontologia. Ela está aqui.
Então, se você olhar retrieval, Pipeline Setting, você vai ver como que a gente.
Quebra esse dado. Como que a gente melhora esse dado. Como que a gente enriquece essa informação, que a partir Daqui Você Usa Como Base Para Poder Criar.
O seu processo.
Então aqui. ó, eu vou deixar pra vocês fazerem perguntas com.
E cem para vocês me reportarem. O que vocês acham? Então, esse é um dos deveres de casa.
Então Wif e Without.
Essa informação. Tá.
Então aqui vamos fazer um.
Mechanology Ask. Então, o que eu posso fazer aqui, ó.
Without Ontology Question Whether Speed live for type one, blah, blah, blah.
Ele explica basicamente naive. Procedure, Guess.
Procedure tal tal tal tal tal tal? Então ele dá a informação básica do que é, né?
Aqui como llm Daria. Ele vai responder para você, cara, ó.
Aqui são as informações. Essas são os campos que estão. E é isso.
é diferente de você perguntar literalmente, o meio que.
Aqui. O Ontology.
Então deixa eu só deixar a diferença aqui.
Um. é? Calma aí.
Cadê.
Deixa eu fazer o seguinte.
What pediu para ele fazer duas perguntas. Aqui tá uma com ele, M e a outra com ontologia pra gente Ver A Diferença Entre Eles.
Deixa ele executar aqui e agora a gente vai para a primeira parte de como a gente.
Organiza tudo isso. Então lembra que eu falei para vocês do Converge, né?
Outra coisa para vocês estudarem, navegar e entender. Aqui tem um mundo de coisas para vocês entenderem.
O que o converge vai fazer?
Ele vai ser a espinha do nosso processo. Então ele vai ser um Framework que a gente vai passar.
Todos os dias para deixar esse cara totalmente organizado e fazer com que a gente execute tudo isso.
Para poder fazer. Consta desse.
Teve gente que tirou férias, inclusive para poder fazer.
Então, por exemplo, o que seria aqui.
Desde o framework do Converge.
Então aqui, ó.
A gente vai ver ele durante a semana, tá? Então fiquem tranquilos.
Dentro do framework do converge.
Ele tem dois passos aqui. Na verdade, ele tem.
Vários passos. O primeiro passo dele é o passo que a gente chama de captura.
Então, olha só. Que legal. Ele vai compilar os arquivos que a gente vai mandar. Então, basicamente.
Dentro desse Framework. O que eu falo para ele é o seguinte. Olha só.
Eu tenho esses arquivos aqui. Executa para mim.
E daí? Ele vai transformar esses arquivos em intenção. E esses intenções? Ele vai organizar isso no business, requirement document Que A Gente Vai Ver Logo Mais.
Tá.
Então, o que a gente vai fazer agora? Eu quero que vocês façam comigo, tá? Isso aqui é importante.
A gente vai instalar a gente. Vai transformar o Brd e o Spec. Vocês vão pirar nisso aqui.
Pirar. Então vamos fazer. Vamos lá. No ambiente.
Vamos no quatorze.
Beleza. Então.
Vamos copiar esse Prompt.
E eu vou explicar um pouquinho aqui enquanto a gente faz isso, tá.
Antes disso? Mesma pergunta. Dois métodos. Mcp, Catálogo West.
Não está né? Vinculado nessa exceção e ontologia.
Vinculado com o Ontology.
Pesquisa natural. Eu perguntei, basicamente, qual a relação.
De o que que page significa para o tipo um.
Então ele bate na palavra.
Beach.
A Ddl não vai falar, Page em nenhum lugar. Então ele não consegue ter ideia do que é.
Então ele adivinha.
Que essa informação, por exemplo, está dentro do cord settlement, mas, na verdade é card settlement.
Outra coisa. Ele chuta cord settlement spade. Mas na verdade é um staging copy.
E a Granularity Transaction Id. Ele literalmente não sabe.
Quando você pergunta para a camada de ontologia. Olha só. Que foda.
Page.
Pelo tipo um é observado no Reporting Card Settlement Reconciliation. O Grown é Bad id mais currency.
Reporting refresh cars and reconciliation. Escreve na tabela. Legacy Apply Rights Applied Money onto legacy card sentiment which to refresh reads.
Ou seja, a gente tem o Linis da informação aqui.
Então ele sabe qual a tabela? Qual grão? Qual o fato.
Qual é literalmente a tabela que é escrita. De onde vem.
Então ele não vai adivinhar se vocês fizeram uma pesquisa densa em cima de ontologia cara, e conseguir ver a Quantidade De Tokens Que Você Gasta.
Enquanto X, ele reverbera para cima quando ele erra. Numa pesquisa.
Em torno de dezessete vezes.
Então você gasta dezessete vezes mais Token.
Se você errar, esse entendimento, que é exatamente o Kyle vai fazer nesse contexto? Ele tem entendimento da Ddl.
Ele entende o significado do que é aquela Ddl.
No converge. O que a gente vai fazer?
Você está no primeiro dia.
Leia o ritmox Cvg System, Spine Html.
Se tiver no disco.
Respondo o seguinte: o que é? Converge.
O que é Task Spec? O que é Simwise? O que é Brief Spec? O que a gente vai rodar hoje.
Como que a gente captura os arquivos.
Como que a gente escreve intenção.
Então vamos ler isso aqui. Que isso aqui é importantíssimo. Tá.
Se eu fosse falar para você. Essa parte mais importante da aula, tá.
Sem entender isso aqui.
Quero mostrar para vocês quem. Que é conversa. O que é? Task Spec? O que é assim mais.
Só no segundo.
Beleza aí, ó.
Ele vai basicamente explicar para mim o que significa.
Esses três carinhas aí.
Olha, então vamos lá.
O que é? Converge, né?
Então, o que a converge.
Converge. é uma espinha. Nove passos, duas fases.
Uma barreira humana.
é uma compilação de intenção.
Que não escreve produto. é um coordenador sobre os sinuais que é decomposição. E o Task Spec, que é a autoridade atômica.
Nunca escreve código.
O Cvg é o Cli que faz tudo isso.
A gente usa o Ciela e conecta. Ele via Skill.
Que ele tem uma Skill. O que é o Task Spec?
Ele transforma uma atividade. Ele transforma o requisito numa atividade atômica.
Que tem estrutura, autorização e voz e critério de aceitação.
Então ele faz toda a parte de tarefa dentro do Converge.
O que é o Sinwise? O Simwise é como eu crio as linhas, né?
é basicamente entender como que o sistema se corta. E ele cria Sunlanes Legs.
E gera um plano para que esse plano possa ser executado via Swim length via desk Spec.
E o que é o Brief Spec? é uma interface de leitura.
O que a gente vai fazer hoje. A gente vai pegar todos os documentos, tá? E a gente vai capturar Essa Intenção Deixa Eu Capturar Os Arquivos.
Que a gente tem aqui. E a gente vai capturar a intenção.
Então a gente vai usar o quê? Os Specs, os arquivos que a gente recebeu.
Para entender a intenção e escrever.
Esses documentos, tá? Vamos dar uma olhadinha. Que legal. Agora.
Como que a gente transforma toda essa complexidade em algo extremamente fácil. Tá.
Então.
Vamos usar.
O.
Converge. Deixa eu ver.
Onde está? Aqui.
Aqui. Está lá, né.
Então, install from luan. Sou Cvgs on Your Path.
Ah, então a primeira coisa que vocês vão fazer. E eu quero ver vocês executando isso. Aqui tá essa parte.
Top do negócio. Então executem.
Install converge. Basicamente, vocês vão falar Install e bota o link para instalar. Pede pra ele me instalar ele para você.
Ele vai instalar aí.
E aí, uma vez que você instale.
A gente vai executar.
Esse Prompt.
O Prompt é basicamente.
Seguinte. Docs.
Brd, Type, Celomin, from.
Entre os casos, informações do Second Brain.
Todas as informações que a gente tem.
E a gente vai pedir para executar o Pé zero.
Tá vendo o pé zero.
E aí, se você vier aqui, ó.
Não converge. Olha que foda. O que é o pé zero.
Para mim, né? O p zero pra.
Yeah, uma ideia ao Brd.
Então ele transforma ideias cruas num arquivo de documentação.
Com voz. Dono.
Informação estruturada.
Tá então when someone says that they have an idea captured this idea write the brief grill the idea start phase zero.
Oi, start paser.
Então, basicamente, eu vou receber um bocado de documento nessa Skill.
Eu vou ler. Eu vou ver se ele nem me entende. Senão ela vai fazer perguntas adicionais para isso.
E daí? Sim, ela pode ir para o primeiro passo, que é transformar esses documentos em requisitos técnicos.
Olha só que foda. Então aqui eu criei uma Skill que é nível zero, que ela é opt in, né?
Muitas das vezes. Você já sabe o que você quer de documento? Muitas das vezes você não tem.
Então, nesse caso, é para a gente transformar todo aquele emaranhado de coisas que a gente não tem.
Em algo extremamente.
Palpável, utilizando o.
Passo zero.
Passe zero. Vai fazer isso?
Então eu estou falando aqui. Você é o Ps.
Pega os documentos que estão dentro de docs, Brd. Quer dizer, gera. Faz um draft de docs. Brd.
Da onde, puxando do Second Brain.
Que é do Brain aqui do notebook? Lm que a gente tem todas as informações, ou seja.
Eu dei uma cacetada de documento para ele. Eu estou pedindo para essa Skill.
Fazer o quê? Organizar esses arquivos?
De uma forma estruturada, para a gente poder usar para a gente ingerir esse documento.
Na primeira fase, realmente do Conve.
Então pense nisso. No projeto canônico, no processo canônico.
Você tem várias coisas.
E daí? Você quer gerar? E daí? Eu fiz uma coisa muito legal, que é o seguinte.
Você tem o chat.
Você tem a Skill.
E a Skill carrega a Cli.
Foda, né? Então bota aí. Você é foda ou não é foda. Então vocês já entenderam agora, né?
Qual a parte foda chat.
Falo. Chama Skill.
Da Skill. Eu chamo o quê? Chama Clay.
Então eu trabalho justamente com isso.
Que eu estou usando Agents Skills.
Bom, né? Então aí, aqui, ó.
Queria fazer. Vou escrever o Brd.
Helena. Voz, blá, blá, blá, Cvg.
Olá. Gerei.
Um business requirement document. Olha isso.
Ele pegou tudo, velho.
E gerou um Intent, o início de um Intent.
Business Card Document Type zero.
Quem perguntou? Second Brain fora de escopo?
O que aconteceu?
Os Samples.
O que significa, Donny?
Mentira.
As informações válidas. Imbound em estrutura.
O que vai ser feito.
Sumário executivo.
Problema. Objetivos: kpis, escopo.
O que está dentro, o que está fora, o que não está decidido.
Definição de sucesso: stakeholders, riscos.
Constraints.
Perguntas que estão abertas para seguir. Lado fonte.
Sign off.
Ele monta esse processo para mim.
Tá? Então a primeira parte do converge é justamente fazer com que você pegue um bocado de documento.
Se joga esses documentos pela primeira esquilla ou primeira Skill valida cria uma estrutura inteira.
Para que você possa injetar.
Literalmente na primeira parte, que é o Intent. A intenção.
Agora eu vou capturar a intenção.
Agora eu vou falar para o meu. Converge.
Seguinte: eu já tenho.
Eu já tenho ali um bocado de documento que eu fiz aqui, que é o Docs Brd settlement.
Usa um pouquinho, tá? Mas não está totalmente alinhado ao processo. Tá? Mas usa.
Um pouco.
Beleza. Então eu pego aqui.
E o que eu vou fazer.
Aquele é o zero. Está escrevendo um documento.
Logo quando ele acabar, eu vou falar. Cara, você é o pé zoom. Agora.
Você vai ler o documento.
E você vai criar um draft do documento.
Que vai virar a intenção do processo como um todo.
Tá.
Law criou o documento primeiro.
Agora ele vai gerar.
O meu documento, que é a intenção. Então o que acontece aqui tá pra vocês entenderem o que é o Brd Docs To Tech Rack.
Então ele transforma.
Um Client Brd que é business Requirement documents. Transforma um business requirement document.
Into a very Fiable Tech Spec.
Então ele vai pegar todas as informações ali que foram compiladas nesse documento que eu fiz posteriormente.
E ele vai achar. Ele vai me perguntar. E a gente vai trabalhar para poder quebrar.
Essas informações realmente para serem transformadas em um documento técnico.
Então, enquanto ele faz isso, vamos só terminar que a gente já está acabando.
De passar aqui nos últimos slides.
Então, o que a gente viu, né? A gente viu que a planta já executa fim a fim.
A gente verificou que o converge. Na verdade, é uma ferramenta.
Determinística, porque eu tenho uma interface chat.
Eu tenho um Skill para cada.
Passo, e esse Skills se mapeia diretamente com uma cli extremamente robusta e complexa, que faz tudo de forma determinística.
E aí a gente também tem o contrato como juiz.
Então por que eu contrato contrato? Vai nos ajudar exatamente nisso? Aqui.
Por quê? Porque durante a semana.
A gente vai construir a linha moderna, né?
A gente aqui em cima está olhando a linha legada. A gente tem o Java.
Tem um arquivo Csv.
Tem um copy. Tem um procedure. Tem um reporting. Tem um oracle para validar. O que a gente vai criar Na Camada De Baixo.
A gente vai traduzir o Java por Python amanhã.
A gente vai escrever esse cara em Park por ser otimizado.
A gente vai ter um Python Dlt, que é para fazer ingestão desse dado.
Já utilizar o Duck. Db e o Duck Lake para trazer essa informação para o parque dentro do Duct. Db.
A gente vai usar o Dbt como Analytics Engineering.
Depois, posteriormente, a gente vai validar essas informações. E, por fim, a gente vai servir orquestrar essa informação inteira com o Bagster.
Lá, Exter vai fazer organização inteira e orquestração inteira desse projeto para a gente.
Whichever escolher darkster. E não é flow. é justamente para ser.
Projeto de orquestração totalmente fora.
Da zona de conforto de dezanove dos engenheiros.
Como eu, por exemplo, tenho pouco conhecimento de Darkstein.
Assim como tem um pouco conhecimento de Java? Tá.
Então a gente literalmente validou a evidência do Ledger. A gente teve certeza.
This. Valor de cento e setenta e três, quarenta e cinco.
Com cada noite.
Eu quero que vocês naveguem no repositório. Então cada noite, eu quero que vocês terminem com pesquisa.
Então, amanhã vocês vão acordar. Vão cheirar um tempo e vocês vão aqui olhar.
O nosso.
Dezessete. Eu quero que vocês façam certas perguntas para o Second Brain.
Eu quero que vocês façam certas perguntas. Pronto, Layer.
Eu quero que vocês verifiquem as informações como um todo.
Então, assim a ideia é vocês utilizarem isso como pesquisa, porque eu vou avançar nessas pesquisas.
Amanhã, tá? Então a ideia é vocês pesquisarem trabalharem esse cara.
Então, basicamente, a gente fez toda parte de contextualização.
A gente vai amanhã avançar.
Na documentação de como a gente vai transmutar essa informação vai ser muito foda.
A gente vai trabalhar, o converge nos próximos passos e a gente vai começar a traduzir.
Dar essas informações.
Tudo vai estar disponível a partir do meio dia de amanhã, tá? Então eu vou receber os transcripts de manhã. Eu Passo Para Dentro Do Repositório Vai Estar Dentro De Uma Pasta Chamada Transcripts.
A apresentação já está no repositório. Tudo que eu mostrei que está no repositório.
E a gravação vai estar após do meio dia. Beleza.
Gente antes de sair. Temos cento e quatro. O que vocês acharam? Gostaram? Fomos fim afim trabalhando. Tem alguns pedaços Que Vocês Ainda Não Resolveram Mas Vocês Viram Um Caminho E Aí Vocês Gostaram Desse Estilo.
Onde vocês vão comigo, trabalham, coloquem no feedback. Deixa eu ver.
Como foi? Já deu para aprender alguma coisa. Foda pra cacete. Também goste.
é.
Já teve algum nuggetzinho bom.
Primeiro dia, né? A gente está ajustando aí a engrenagem.
Mas curti bastante. Amanhã a gente vai começar. A tradução vai olhar na lente.
De um swa. Sw, Né. São um software Engineer.
E eu curti também pra mim foi muito foda, beleza. Então vamos descansar. Que a gente precisa de energia ao longo dessa semana.
Que a gente vai acelerando o dia a dia.
Beleza. Vejo vocês amanhã. Então.
Tá? Oito horas e até mais.
Alôred.
Como que ele vai desenvolver essa solução de forma local e como a gente vai deploy isso depois em algum outro lugar então o que a.